[Musique]
le cern
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis là city venus je suis dit deux
animatrices sur ce soir notre network se
compose essentiellement d'électeurs
indécis ils sont ici même au coeur de
l'action sur le plateau il faut savoir
cependant que leur avons demandé
d'éviter d'applaudir pendant les débats
afin de favoriser savoir également avant
de commencer que nous allons aborder
cinq grands chelems et ce soir il
choisit en fonction des questions que se
posent et canadiens et qu'ils veulent
que l'on débatte
nous avons reçu plus de huit mille
questions les thèmes de ce soir donc ce
en fonction de ses questions ses
débiteurs et y répondrons en entre qui a
été établi par un petit rat chaussoy
nous voulons un débat de ce soir les
spectateurs veulent c'est pourquoi le
chef se sont entendus pour respecter
leur tendresse ce soir le premier thème
leadership au canada et sur la scène
internationale la première question de
reagan lit ici même dans l'auditoire un
grand nombre de canadiens
est ce que le canada est beaucoup plus
divisé maintenant qu'en 2015 se souvient
le protectionnisme américain auprès du
site
les tensions croissantes et les clashes
out your en tant que premier de fait
comment il est entré vous les intérêts
et valeurs des canadiens sur la scène
internationale merci beaucoup monsieur
trudeau vous avez le droit de parole en
premier
vous savez avec nous ce soir et merci à
vous tous et toutes de vous joindre à
nous en ce moment très important pour
parler de l'avenir de notre pays et vous
permettre de comparer les différentes
formules telles que nous avons et nous
vivons une ère est difficile de
protection sur la base des quatre
dernières années nous avons dans les
canadiens pour que les gens sont
optimistes le rapport est l'avenir pour
qui sait les outils pour connaître
succès et aussi pour choeur enfantin
oui nous avons surmonté des défis dit
nous avons le vent aussi bien sur des
édifices économie de demain
qu'est ce qui nécessite que nous des
gens les autres chefs
ici celle sur les mondialistes ils
dépensent votre jeu se payer aussi un
jeu au conseil de sécurité des nations
unies donne votre argent à d'autres pays
pour lutter contre le changement
climatique pour construire des routes en
afrique
l'onu est un organisme dysfonctionnelle
nous devons être en mesure de nous
battre pour notre pays
à l'heure actuelle nous sommes le seul
parti qui aiment politique étrangère
vraiment fondées sur une autre propre
sécurité et tout sur notre prospérité
maintenant beaucoup les sans merci
beaucoup ri gun pour votre question et
ça doit difficile de poser une question
d'avoir une fois comme ça et merci au
canada d'être avec nous ce soir pour
cette section pour moi le leadership a
tout à voir avec comment vous vous
battez et si vous le faites ce que ce
qu'il veut faire pour les gens et qu'il
s'agisse d'affaires internationale de se
tenir debout devant le parc de négocier
de meilleurs entend commercial pour moi
ça ce résultat est ce qu'on a le courage
pour se tenir debout devant les intérêts
puissants les soucier des grandes
sociétés qui ont trop d'affluence au
canada et jusqu'à présent canada se soit
également un conservateur ou libéral
n'ont pas eu le courage de se tenir de
hauts
nous sommes différents je travaille pour
les gens il peut pas se souvenir le
nombre de fois qu'il a été en photo
blackface il affiche toujours un masque
il affiche un masque pour la
réconciliation
il est congédié son procureur général
autochtone ils oeuvrent congédié deux de
ces éminentes ministre qui est le
prétend défendre la classe moyenne mais
monsieur trudeau vous êtes info vous
êtes double et vous ne méritez pas de
gouverner le canada
niveau répondre à la question que l'on
grille d'entendre j'aimerais tout
d'abord commencé en reconnaissant que
nous sommes sur le territoire est le
tunnel des populations algonquine mais
qu'on les tue un mandat à une réputation
donner à tout et nous sommes un pic de
fin 2006 l'athéisme nyon comme nation
nous sommes engagés de respecter les
objectifs de développement durable ce
qui veut dire que notre avenir dépend
il faut mettre fin à la pauvreté doit
encourager l'éducation des femmes des
filles ça c'est tout simple qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire
il faut également renégocié
l'organisation un mondial du colleur se
faire en sorte que l'on fasse la
promotion des mesures climatiques
nous avons besoin d'une organisation
internationale pour les migrations
climatiques
il faut également appuyé la suprématie
du droit à l'échelle nationale puisque
la question où les valeurs bien sûr je
ne deviendrai a probablement le premier
ministre d'abord soir à tous et à toutes
de montrer du doigt le fait d'hériter de
rui sur les producteurs de porcs de ceux
qui ont réécrit
quand on fait face à de dangereux
ati cuisse en carbone de la chine on ne
serait pas présent force qu'ont
soutiendrait quelqu'un avec un véritable
de leadership continu en trois thèmes
pour que national c'est avant tout de
poser une question au nom des caennais
été choisis par tirage au sort
la question suivante s'adresse donc aux
maxime verdier tous les autres chefs ont
ensuite eu l'occasion de vous aimer
beaucoup envoyer des tweets mais
permettez moi d'en lire certains à
ottumwa vous avez qualifié la diversité
au canada de sectes et de musique et
réalisme extrême que vous avez employé
les mots ghetto et tribus pour décrire
les nouveaux venus qui vous volent une
communité pourrait semer la méfiance est
potentiellement la violence or une
créature borg
la militante pour le climat qui a à
peine 16 ans vous dites qu'elle est
perturbé mentalement s'agite et là des
paroles d'une personne qui à l'intégrité
de mener le canadien il nous représente
et sur la scène internationale
merci de votre question écoutez il faut
dire la vérité au ghana si on veut
diriger le pays en ce que je dis au
sujet du culturalisme multiculturalisme
extrême c'est que on ne va pas
construire mon pays comme ça nous devons
être fiers de notre pays
oui du multiculturalisme mais on n'a pas
besoin d'une loi pour me dire qui nous
sommes nous sommes un pays diversifié
nous en sommes fiers
est ce que je dis au sujet de
l'immigration c'est tout simplement
qu'il faut moins d'immigrés et il faut
s'assurer que les gens qui arrivent vont
participer à notre société
nous avons un grand pays mais il est
temps de discuter du dossier
d'immigration
nous voulons pas que notre pays soit g
les pays européens on a beaucoup de
difficulté à
les immigrants moi je suis canadien le
canadien est fier de son pays et je suis
le seul chef ici qui est prêt à discuter
d'une vigueur si nous allons donc avoir
un débat des plus animées ce soir car
c'est au tour de monsieur sindh en
débattre avec monsieur bernier sur cette
question à savoir le tempérament d'un
bon leader monsieur bernier après avoir
entendu ce qui vient d'être dit vous
auriez pu dire je me suis trompé parce
que c'est pas mal horrible ce que vous
avez dit vous devriez pas de ce prix je
crois qu'un leader ce n'est pas
quelqu'un qui doit diviser les gens ou
qui doit les monter les uns contre les
autres c'est quelqu'un qui tente de
trouver des ponts les rassembler ses 5
en 1 et des refaire les dents est là
pour les gens qui ont besoin des mollahs
d'aider les gens qui sont les plus
riches
les corps ne ment tahoua travaille
depuis longtemps à faciliter la vie aux
millionnaires a envoyé à donner des
réductions d'impôts société 1 ce n'est
pas la façon de construire un pays où
les canadiens fou aider les canadiens
mais pas avec des moules à paris
personne parce que ses nuits à tout le
monde ce n'est pas ici il faut de la
croissance économique au comme ce
dernier il faut redonner aux canadiens
selon des besoins
c'est parce que je me permets de vous
rappeler qu'il s'agit bien bel et bien
dans le débat mais que les spectateurs
ont dû de l'activité à comprendre qui
que ce soit si tout le monde parle en
même temps dans cette partie du débat on
peut en débattre avec monsieur bernier
mais maintenant c'est au tour de
monsieur chu d'en débattre avec monsieur
bernier sur la question du leadership
monsieur bernier n'a pas compris qu'on
peut être très fière de l'histoire
canadienne on peut être fier de son
identité fiers de nos réalisations ici
et ailleurs dans le monde tout en
accueillant des gens de partout dans le
monde
c'est l'un des atouts
au canada les gens viennent au canada
grâce àdes pour notre liberté
et pour la liberté d'expression
l'égalité entre les jambes monsieur
bernier la liberté de religion
vous avez changé avant d'oser vous
croyez dans un système d'immigration qui
étaient justes équitables compatissant
et maintenant vous tirez votre
inspiration des parties les plus sombres
de la société oui mais côté moi ce que
je veux c'est un pays c'est un pays
je ne veux pas se débride de choses oui
vous pouvez le faire vous pouvez le
faire mais sans insulter ceux qui
viennent au canada
vraiment c'est la différence entre
monsieur bernier et moi nous croyons qu
on peut renforcer le canada n'augmentant
notre population et en célébrant toutes
ont réalisé sur le même sujet j'ai bien
compris la question on lit ça vous avez
également posé une question sur les
caractéristiques dont il faut faire
preuve pour faire preuve de leadership
le leadership c'est rendre service
qu'est ce qui fait un bon premier
ministre
eh bien il faut le reconnaître que nous
sommes là pour desservir la population
générale on n'est pas là pour dire quoi
parlez vous servir la population
générale
bon tout à l'heure aux ags qui va se
faire et éviter au parlement où on n'est
pas invité on essaie d'aller travailler
pour les gens et moi je crois qu'il faut
faire preuve de leadership en dedans le
service bon maxime bernier ce qu'il a
dit c'est vraiment épouvantable
il connaît mon opinion il sait on
s'assoit yale à côté de l'autre et il
sait que quand il parle à jeter vais me
tenir la tête entre les deux mais parce
que je vous invite je vous aime bien
mais je ne ferait tache pas nouveau
idées socialistes et vos politiques
écoutez on ne sera pas capable de créer
des emplois avec votre politique ce sont
des politiques de pays socialistes comme
le venezuela
on ne crée pas de richesse admettez le
dans ces pays là il ne se créé par tim
richesse l'injure économique vous avez
un programme 60 milliards de dollars ce
n'est pas responsable économie c'est ce
qu'il faut faire pour villa
l'immigration j'ai rien d'immigration
que j'appelais des migrations et qui
sont pro immigration c'est la même chose
merci madame mais maintenant monsieur
blanchet aura l'occasion d'en débattre
avec mathieu bernier lui vous allez me
laisser combien de secondes avant de me
d'intervenir
bon quand quelqu'un kiev que la vérité
ne devrait pas nier les changements
climatiques et le mot socialisme semble
être un peu facile à 10 secondes
l'immigration n'est pas une question de
chiffres
c'est une question de ressources dans
lesquels on investit pour que ces
personnes se sentent les bienvenus au
canada et au québec en vue qu'ils
puissent se partager notre langue
partager certaines de nos valeurs et si
nous disposons de suffisamment de
ressources
cela est possible à réaliser en effet
pas en envoyer un message pour qu'il ne
se sente pas bienvenue et vous savez 49
% des sociétés sont d'avis qu'il faut
avoir moins de 10 microns ce ne sont pas
des racistes
pourquoi moi parce que je suis d'accord
avec la majorité de la population avec
la majorité des canadiens et ce nouveau
invité je n'ai pas raison nous avons le
soin de débattre des idées c'est ce que
ce faire vous a dit que vous avez le
droit aussi d éminemment sommes tous si
nous en sommes sur des missions des
canadiens pierre et merci et le dernier
débat sur ce sujet monsieur trudeau et
monsieur bernier le tempérament d'un
leader je pense qu'il est important de
reconnaître que le monde dans lequel
nous vivons est un monde où ces
discussions cette autorisation ou cette
crainte de l'autre est devenu quelque
chose que certains politiciens décident
d'attiser lorsqu'ils veulent attiser
l'incertitude dans le coeur des gens ce
qu'ils veulent que les gens votent
contre des choses malheureusement
monsieur bernier
ici ce soir joue ce rôle ils tentent de
soulever la peur chez les gens par
rapport aux migrations qui se déroule
par rapport aux occasions
ce 4è la mondialisation chaque jour nous
avons la chance de redéfinir ce que l'on
entend par être canadien et oui ça va
évoluer
oui ça va se transformer au fil du temps
au fur et mesure que nous avançons nous
vous les blonds vous jouez à l'arrêt de
diversité sont célébrées partout dans
l'eau doit aussi parler de notre
identité souligné qu'ils nous sommes je
suis canadien
je suis fier de l'est comme vous nous
avons construit ce pays ensemble et ont
vu que ce pays soit 25 ans et on l'a
dans le pays
je veux discuter de l'immigration et ce
dernier autant notre romain si ce mot si
ce pont simplement de dire publiquement
ce que monsieur scheer pas en seulement
personnel 100 % des canadiens veulent
davantage d'immigrants seulement 6%
donc si vous ne voulez pas faire débat
vous vous ne prenez pas la même langue
que la population des bâtons de ce sujet
si lyon est sur scène nous voulons
maintenant entend la voix d'un autre
canadien ce soir car cette question est
si complexe à cette question vient de
susan fernando qui pose sa question
depuis calgary
bonjour je m'appelle suzanne freinant
dob de calgary le plus souvent les
gouvernements provinciaux et fédéral ne
semble pas être sur la même longueur
d'onde et ce tous partis confondus
or la coopération est clé dans
l'atteinte de nos objectifs par exemple
les patients les droits des travailleurs
l'éducation les soins de santé comme
premier ministre comment ils sont sûrs
et vous un leadership fort tout en
collaborant avec les provinces et
territoires
merci soutient fernando de calgary une
fois de plus par tirage au sort à cette
question s'adresse à monsieur bernier en
premier et ensuite tous les autres chefs
auront l'occasion d'y répondre
bon tout d'abord tout d'abord je vais
respecter la constitution je vais
respecter les provinces et c'est très
important je ne veux pas me mêler des
champs de compétence des provinces que
ce soit la santé par exemple puisque
c'est une compétence provinciale
et vous savez avatar nous ne pouvons pas
régler tous les défis en matière de
santé pour compte qu'on peut faire c'est
inspiré les fonds ou province et ce que
je ferai c'est ensuite laissé les
provinces s'occuper d'éducation
s'occuper de la santé
c'est ce que dit la constitution il y
aurait des transferts de la tps les
professeurs l argent pour répondre à
vous monsieur bernier et maintenant s'il
vous plaît beaucoup
j'aimerais remercier suzanne pour sa
question d'abord en fait elle a formulé
plusieurs préoccupations
les choses sont de plus en plus
difficile elle a parlé des pensions des
soins de santé
j'aimerais me concentrer sur les soins
de la santé c'est une des préoccupations
majeures quand je rencontre des gens à
travers le pays
j'ai rencontré un jeune garçon qui a une
maladie chronique et sa famille doit
payer pour des injections des
médicaments et et sa plus grande
inquiétude c'est d'être un fardeau pour
son père et sa mère qui n'ont pas les
moyens de payer les médicaments et les
grandes pharmaceutiques sont plus
importantes pour monsieur trudeau que la
santé déjà des gens nous allons
instaurer une assurance médicaments pour
tout le monde
mais si c'est merci monsieur chez eux à
vous de répondre
les conservateurs ont toujours reconnu
l'importance de travailler avec les
provinces nous respectons la compétence
des provinces
mais nous comprenons qu'il faut
également du leadership à l'échelle
fédérale pour que nos projets voient le
voit le jour quelque chose comme le
commerce interprovincial
mais je voudrais dire aux électeurs
partout au pays
les premiers ministres provinciaux
n'auront pas à saisir les tribunaux pour
lutter contre la taxe carbone
cette taxe carbone augmente le coût des
biens essentiels les sciences le
chauffage résidentiel et l'épicerie et
ça va nous faire qu'augmenter après les
prochaines élections il refuse de dire
aux canadiens
quel sera le coût de sa taxe carbone
s'il est réélu le gouvernement
conservateur a abolit de votre question
le parti vert collaboration il faut
régler les problèmes ensemble on ne peut
pas être nous voulons un conseil de
gouvernement canadien dans le
gouvernement fédéral les revirements des
provinces et des territoires
et si les municipalités les
administrations locales et les leaders
autochtones l'ip la nation limiter les
inuit
tout le monde doit être réunis autour de
la même table pour que nous puissions
nous entendre sur les questions urgentes
comme les soins de santé l'urgence
climatique il faut travailler ensemble
comme adam mais merci monsieur blanchet
c'était vaudrait petit si je me souviens
bien j'ai pris connaissance d'une étude
aujourd'hui éric ulpat monsieur montigny
disant que ce n'est pas uniquement un
enjeu québécois et provincial aussi si
on veut coopérer avec les provinces et
avec le québec
il faut donc respecter les champs de
compétence provinciaux et il faut
arrêter de faire certaines choses et
c'est une des demandes du québec
on ne veut pas que notre argent soutenu
en otage par le gouvernement fédéral et
re donner d'autre part au québec
assortie de conditions
il faut respecter les gens de compétence
des provinces et ne pas émerger à vous
de répondre souligne de cinar peur
pendant dix ans il a décidé d'arrêter de
rencontrer les premiers ministres des
provinces et nous avons remis cela au
programme lorsque nous sommes arrivés au
pouvoir nous avons renforcé leur pc pour
toute une génération
nous avons aussi signé des accords en
matière de santé historiquement investit
beaucoup dans les soins de santé à la
maison dans la santé mentale ont investi
dans les infrastructures dans le
logement dans les transports en commun
partout au pays nous continuons à
travailler avec les provinces sur la
renégociation d'un alignement et tout le
monde lors de la renégociation jouer
pour la même équipe en quelque sorte
alors nous luttons sûr en fait l'enjeu
principal de notre de notre époque parce
que jason kenny dope foule et d'autres
leurs consommateurs ne veulent rien
faire en ce qui a trait aux changements
climatiques
nous on va être un gouvernement au
canada qui va lutter au nom des
canadiens contre les changements
climatiques exactement ce que nous
allons faire nous aurons un débat libre
sous peu nous allons maintenant changer
de sujet et permettre un chef de poser
une question à un autre chef sur le
sujet de son choix
encore une fois l'ordre a été déterminé
par un tirage au sort le premier chef
cette fois ci sera le chef du parti
néo-démocrate monsieur c'est que vous
avez grandi sa dose pour monsieur
trudeau vous parlez souvent la façon
dont les consommateurs ont réduit les
impôts pour les plus riches et ont
réduit les services jeu l'accord avec
vous ma question et vous critiquer
monsieur harper sur ces cibles
environnementales vous ne les avez pas
atteint vous même vous critiquer
monsieur harper sur les réductions dans
les soins de santé vous avez fait la
même chose vous
vous avez donné 14 milliards de plus aux
sociétés qui mesure à peu pourquoi vous
laissez tomber les gens qui ont voté
pour vous la première chose que nous
avons fait ces deux raisons les impôts
de la classe moyenne et nous avons
augmenté pour les canadiens les mieux
nantis le 1% et après 10 ans d'inaction
du gouvernement harper sur les
changements climatiques en quatre ans
seulement nous avons réussi à atteindre
115 centres objectif pour 2030
nous allons atteindre cet objectif ne
l'ont même surpasser même sens que c'est
pas si nous allons en faire davantage en
plantant deux milliards d'arbres et
aussi en donnant de l'argent pour que
les gens puissent rénover leur maison
on veut aussi que le canada certains
pays à zéro émission est ici 2050 nous
savons à quel point il est important
d'aller de l'avant et à l'heure actuelle
monsieur scheer pour sa part a promis
que la première chose qu'il ferait
c'est qu'il allait écarter le premier la
première stratégie de lutte contre les
changements climatiques a eu le canada
au contraire nous allons avancer parce
que c'est ce à quoi s'attendent les
canadiens nous avons réussi à sortir des
centaines de milliers de personnes de la
pauvreté grâce à nos investissements
dans les familles grâce à la location
indienne pour enfants est d'ailleurs le
npd monsieur singh le voter contre
certaines ces mesures nous allons
continuer à aller de l'avant crée des
emplois
sortir les gens de la pauvreté parce que
c'est ce à quoi s'attendre les qualités
c'est ce que nous allons continuer de
faire maintenant tous les chefs père
veut en débattre sur cette même question
pendant quatre minutes juste le dire
nous regardons le bilan de ce
gouvernement est en réalité c'est canal
a dit qu'en 2017 les plus riches ont
payé moins d'impôts et ont accumulé plus
de richesse est un des plus gros
problème auquel nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui ce sont les paradis fiscaux
non seulement votre ministre des
finances a utilisé des paradis fiscaux
mais le président du conseil du trésor
également à utiliser des paradis fiscaux
comment pouvez vous dire aux canadiennes
et canadiens que vous n'avez pas
l'argent pour financer une assurance
médicaments lorsque vous vous avez des
ministres qui ne paient pas leur juste
part monsieur singh plus tôt
vous la ressemblance est frappante
désolé nous avons eu un combat que nous
avons mené contre les conservateurs et
les néo nazis les mines anti lorsque
nous avons mis fin aux échappatoires
fiscales que veut rouvrir monsieur
scheer
il veut donner des crédits d'impôts des
mots question d'organiser les mines anti
nous allons aller de l'avant nous allons
investir dans les canalisations trudeau
nous allons donner l'occasion pour
monsieur cherche des réponses
vous avez dit que les propriétaires de
petites entreprises des petites
entreprises c'était des fraudeurs et en
même temps vous avez protéger votre
fiducie et vos amis milliardaires
nous on veut baisser les impôts pour
tous les canadiens on a un crédit plutôt
une baisse d'impôts universelle qui
veulent donner des centaines de dollars
de plus et un couple moyenne intervenir
ce que vous faites pour faire ce que
vous dépensez vous dépensez non les
réductions d'impôts c'est pas des
dépenses ils m'ont tout le monde dépense
de plus en plus or on ne peut pas créer
de la richesse quand le gouvernement se
contente de dépenser de l'argent il faut
lé bonne politique pour aider les
entrepreneurs il faut que le secteur
privé puisse investir c'est le secteur
privé qui va devenir du papier brun
budget personne et c'est pour sa
complété par ces hausses d'impôts malam
et vous aimeriez intervenir
monsieur singh a souligné que monsieur
trudeau n'a pas changé les objectifs en
matière climatique
objectif qui avait été établi il faut le
répéter et je suis déçu parce que
je croyais les libéraux en 2015
lorsqu'ils disaient qu'ils allaient axé
leurs politiques sur les faits qui me
soucie du domaine et on va perdre la
nuit contre les changements climatiques
avec ces objectifs là parce que ils font
fi des conseils du giec et des
scientifiques
ce soir nous sommes le seul parti si
nous avons un plan mission impossible
c'est le seul plan il va réellement qui
nous permettrait d'avoir une économie
carboneutre d'ici 2050
non vos statistiques ne sont pas
suffisantes
autre plat elle celui ci est quelqu'un
de suite avec le rapport de conseil dont
15,5 degrés comme réchauffement vous
adorez dire ça pour quoi et bien parce
qu'ils vont être suivis de nauzan
heureusement pour s'attaquer à la crise
climatique dans lequel nous sommes
il va falloir du courage pour lutter
contre les grands pollueurs et va
pouvoir se tenir debout devant les
lobbies de la lys devant lequel monsieur
trudeau s'est s'est agenouillé et le
faut cesser de verser des subventions au
secteur des les experts sont d'accord
ce qu'un plan sur luge changement
climatique doit être cet être ambitieux
et réalisables et parmi les plans sur
les changements climatiques que l'on
entend ce soir il y en a un qui était
qualifié de réalisable et d'ambitieux
par les experts c'est le nom c'est celui
que nous avons mis de l'avant le plan de
monsieur trudeau ne marche pas tout
coûte plus cher pour les travailleurs
canadiens
il a donné une exemption aux plus grands
émetteurs
grâce à notre plan nous allons lutter
contre les changements climatiques à
l'échelle mondiale on veut exporter nos
technologies propres et aider d'autres
pays à réduire leurs émissions c'est
tout le temps dont nous disposons pour
ce débat libre et cela conclut ce
segment vous avez l'occasion de prendre
la parole il fallait intervenir alors
merci
c'est la conclusion de ce segment
[Musique]
bonjour je suis un fils branche de
rapidité de postes canada
ce thème est le segment sur la
polarisation les droits de personnes et
l'immigration j'ai commencé avec le chef
néodémocrate jack beats in j'aimerais
d'abord vous poser une question sur la
loi de votre contact sur le courage
cependant vous n'avez pas fait preuve de
courage dans la lutte contre la loi
discriminatoire du québec
cette loi interdit l'accès à des impros
précieux de personnes qui comme vous
pour des symboles religieux succès du
premier ministre perd métairie vous aux
provinces de faire preuve de
discrimination contre leurs propres
citoyens
n'êtes vous pas tout comme les autres
chefs ici en train de faire passer les
intérêts de votre parti au québec au
détriment de vos principes et idées
droit de l'égalité de tous les canadiens
examinions c'est pour le moins évident
aux gens qui me regardent qui nous
regardent que je suis je signe religieux
c'est quelque chose qui me fait de la
peine quand on se fait dire bon on
disait que je dois pas faire certaines
choses en raison de la façon de mon
allure est bon les gens souvent
identifier l'identité est là et les gens
québec se font dire parce qu'ils portent
un voile qui ne peut pas être un
enseignant ou qui ne peuvent pas
travailler comme juge et je pense que
bon c'est mon temps et je pense je suis
contre cela ce que quand je vais au
québec tous les jours j je suis ici je
crois qu'il faut se battre contre les
changements climatiques
je crois fermement et sans équivoque à
au droit d'une femme de choisir et de
créer plus d'accès aux services
d'avortement et je veux qu'on s'attaque
aux grandes sociétés qui influencent le
gouvernement et qui
conteste notre capacité d'aider les gens
changent fait ça tous les jours
monsieur chez eux monsieur signes et
vous même vous pouvez je le suis cette
question d'abord j'aimerais vous
féliciter pour votre la façon dont vous
avez traiter ces questions de race
d'identité vous avez été victimes
d'agressions par le passé on entendu des
scandales le pendant la campagne
électorale également c'est important de
comprendre que nous n'allons pas
intervenir dans cette affaire
le parti conservateur défend toujours la
liberté l'égalité et les libertés
individuelles pour ça non juste des
pierres de ces discussions la
polarisation bon projet de loi 21 20
vous savez les gens pays sont se font
monter les uns contre les autres
donc les gens qui ne peuvent pas trouver
un logement on ne peut pas payer leurs
médicaments ou l'eau ou leurs factures
se font dire que ce n'est pas la faute
des gens des grandes sociétés ou des
gens qui ne paient pas leur juste pas
c'est la faute des immigrants ou des
réfugiés ou quelqu'un qui travaille 12
heures par jour et voilà pourquoi il est
tellement important pour nous de nous
attaquer à l'insécurité automatique
merci monsieur à vous de prendre la
parole avec monsieur c'est sur cette
question j'aimerais l'italie les
commentaires de m zhu cheng mythe
dernièrement les choses on est étrange
nous sommes en période électorale et
nous avons vu plusieurs injures des
questions de privilège et toute personne
blanche à ce petit village
mais si on prend ce sur quoi j'ai droit
28e cette fois au québec
c'est un défi pour nous tous comme c'est
le cas pour les néo démocrates le parti
vert s'oppose à ce projet de loi alors
on se pose la question quelle est la
meilleure façon c'est un gouvernement
fédéral que le protéger les droits de la
personne au sein du québec
eh bien les québécois il ya certains
groupes pour québec quiconque est ce que
cette décision devant les tribunaux il
est ce que
que je dois faire partie de faire plus
de discrimination et franchement nous
sommes dans une situation où nous ne
roulons pas nuire à ce déballage un
terrien que j'aimerais aborder également
non bien que le projet de loi 21
polarise les gens vous avez des bons il
faut s'attaquer aux grandes sociétés qui
ne paient pas leur juste pas et c'est à
partir des raisons pour laquelle les
gens ne fait pas bien gagner leur vie ne
peut pas trouver de logement ou avoir
accès aux médicaments dont ils ont
besoin parce que les gens les plus
riches ne paient pas leur juste part
mesdames et d'action à la merci monsieur
blanchet à votre tour est bien plus que
vous êtes bien aimable soixante dix pour
cent de la population du québec appuie
le projet de loi 21 70 % de parlement
québécois l'appui également de ce n'est
pas une question qui polarise les
québécois et voilà le problème en
anglais et aujourd'hui c'est clair
chacun ici a des problèmes avec l'idée
de la laïcité n'a pas vraiment de
traduction en anglais pour seulement
dans le meilleur des cas vous dites que
vous allez tolérer ce projet de loi mais
le québec n'a pas à se faire dire quoi
faire mais surtout ce projet de loi qui
dit que les gens raison de leur
apparence il ne peut pas faire leur
travail que c'est fou que d'avoir ça et
vous avez dit que je blanche est ce
qu'on devrait faire blanche est plutôt
de faire cela on devrait dire protégeant
les droits des femmes un plus de
protection que veut dire rassemblés dans
le contexte dans lequel j'ai mise en eau
des protections à la communauté lgbt q
tentons d'accord merci merci monsieur
blanchet monsieur singh messieurs
trudeau et monsieur singh peuvent en
débattre maintenant monsieur singh vous
avez parlé de façon fort éloquemment ce
jeu de la discrimination
il avait lutté contre les
discriminations toute votre vie et il
serait raison pour laquelle c'est si
surprenant de vous entendre dire comme
tout autre leader sur le sur la scène ce
soir c'est un événement fédéral sous
votre gouverne n'interviendrait pas dans
le cadre de questions du projet de loi
21 au québec oui bien sûr ça vous met
dans une mauvaise façon politique parce
que comme le dit monsieur blanchet c'est
très populaire au québec mais je suis le
seul qui soit sur la scène ce soir qui
est dit que oui il est possible qu'un
gouvernement fédéral doivent intervenir
parce que le gone en fédérale doit
protéger les droits des minorités les
droits linguistiques 3 protéger les
droits des femmes et doit le faire
partout au pays
vous m'avez pas dit que vous auriez que
vous allez peut-être été revenir vous
avez laissé la porte ouverte à cette
possibilité
chaque jour de ma vie je le lance je
donnais l'autre maintien moi je je je
mets les gens défie tous les jours de ma
vie je je canalise la frustration des
gens il ya plusieurs déjà près de
l'abbaye qui se fond qui se font dire on
peut pas réaliser telle qu'elle changera
raison de leur apparence ne pas agir en
fonction de vos convictions de premier
ministre d'accord merci monsieur bernier
vous pouvez en débattre avec monsieur
singh en ce qui concerne le projet de
loi 21 pour respecter la constitution et
au niveau fédéral
on doit respecter les décisions prises
par les gouvernements provinciaux sait
ce qu'on doit faire
il ya autre chose messieurs si vous
dites que vous ne voulez pas que je sois
ici pour en discuter de ces questions là
vous êtes en faveur de la diversité mais
qu en est il de la diversité des points
de vue des opinions - j'ai le droit
d'avoir une opinion différente de la
vôtre au sujet de
migration vous êtes le chef de parti
vous voulez que tout le monde vous
suivent c'est mon lapin d'applications
jeux pour écouter allez vous écouter des
gens qui disent des choses que vous
voulez entendre c'est tout je vais y
répondre
après deux ou trois minutes de ce débat
ce soir les gens peuvent voir clairement
pourquoi vous ne méritez pas cette
plateforme
c'est une chose de dire que vous êtes en
désaccord avec quelqu'un c'est pas un
problème mais quand vous inciter les
gens à m
je ne sais quand vous le faites de façon
à la haine au courant vous m'en parlez
d'instabilité mentale du jeune fille ça
démontre un manque de jugement vous ne
méritez pas une plate forme et je suis
heureux de vous mettre des filatures vos
idées sont nocifs pour le canada et moi
je suis imitée date en mairie au cou
merci monsieur bernier messieurs c'est
un continent avec le thème de la
polarisation des droits de la personne
et les migrations des gens partout au
pays regardent ce débat y compris une
grande foule à l'immeuble de
l'association étudiante allure stylée
colombie-britannique nous avons
maintenant un public de vancouver à luzy
bonjour bonsoir bonsoir je suis prêt je
m'excuse je suis ici à l'inversé de la
bourde colombie-britannique ce soit mais
j'habite à cordes crime en colombie
britannique
ma question porte sur la polarisation le
canada me semble plus divisé que jamais
si la diversité est notre force
mais la division et notre faiblesse
commun allez-vous vous assurer que vous
avez une vision unifiée au canada et
vous assurer que toutes les voix de tous
les horizons politiques soient entendues
et tenu en compte
merci vous avez 40 secondes vais-je
merci beaucoup pour votre question je
suis reconnaissant d'avoir la chance de
vous parler quand vous parlez des
divisions que nous vivons dans le pays
il y en a plusieurs
elles vont en augmentant mais moi je
pense que plusieurs raisons il la
radicalisation
il ya des discours haineux il ya un
climat qui permet aux gens d'être plus
audacieux mais une des raisons c'est que
les gens s'inquiètent de leur avenir il
ya beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas accès
aux choses de base comme le logement les
médicaments et c'est réellement la
négligence des gouvernements précédents
qui nous a menés là je pense que là je
pense qu'il faut que les gens aient
accès aux choses
ces messieurs c'est très important de
comprendre pourquoi le canada est à ce
point est multiculturelle et c'est par
ce qui est des gens qui viennent de
partout dans le monde et qui viennent y
élire domicile
pourquoi parce qu'ils aspirent aux
libertés individuelles chez nous quels
que soient leur génération quelle que
soit la région du monde
ils sont les bienvenus c'est important
de s'en souvenir de le promouvoir et de
veiller à ce qu'on ait poussé valeur
mais voici ce qui est dangereux quand on
a un premier ministre comme justin
trudeau qui se servent de la race et des
paroles haineuses pour démoniser tous
ceux qui sont en désaccord avec lui
merci beaucoup monsieur c'est le genre
de chose qui sème la démission et
bonsoir vous colombie-britannique jamais
dit bonjour aux territoires masse comme
cv tous trois méchants
donc nous ne voulons pas que les gens se
tournent le dos ou politiques nous
devons ramener l'île et de la réelle
démocratie où chaque citoyen a le
pouvoir de travailler ensemble mission
possible c'est ce que nous disons pour
agir pour le climat il faut que tout le
monde mette l'épaule à la roue
nous avons besoin de tout le monde pour
cette démocratie et il faut que les
élections soient faits de façon juste il
faut se débarrasser du système
majoritaire uninominal à un tour parce
que ça crée des rivalités moi ma mère
sélection il
merci madame et monsieur blanchet oui
bien je crois que la démocratie est
favorisée par l'information donc quand
on traduit voté par des gens qui vous
ressemble
voté par des gens qui vous ressemble
physiquement c'est dans le meilleur des
cas malhonnête et j'aimerais vous
rappeler qu'en 2011 la même phrase a été
dit par michael ignatieff est qu en 2015
phrase a été reprise par thomas mulcair
c'est tout le temps dont vous disposez
monsieur trudeau c'est 40 secondes pour
chaque chef s'est passé à 40 secondes
tout le monde a le même temps pour en
débattre
merci puis je votre question je serais
heureux de voir tout le monde rit nul ne
sait de combien retenu que j'ai déjà été
moi-même louis
c'est vrai nous vivons une époque de
polarisation et beaucoup de différences
ont mis en exergue par les débats que
l'on entend ici et pas deux campagnes
électorales mais la question savoir
comment on va aller de l'avant mais la
réalité ce que la plupart des canadiens
sont d'accord sur les mêmes sujets nous
voulons élever nos enfants dans un monde
meilleur pour eux on veut pouvoir payer
pour leur avenir on veut pouvoir avoir
une retraite confortable en vue créer
des débouchés pour nos voisins
voilà qui unit les canadiens partout au
pays le fait qu'il y ait cette politique
de peur et les divisions ce courant
politique qui est encore présent ici et
bien et sa mine tout ce que nous tentons
de faire monsieur bernier j'écoutais
quand il est question de l'immigration
on ne parle pas de polarisation en fait
le canada accueille plus d'immigrants
par habitant que tout autre pays
occidental trois fois plus que les états
unis
donc il faut en discuter c'est
l'équivalent de toute la démographie de
la nouvelle écosse tous les trois ans
toute la population de nouvelle écosse
qui arrive dans l'immigration au canada
au bout de trois ans alors il est temps
de parler de l'immigration est d'avoir
un système
c'est pourquoi il faut accueillir moins
d'immigrants et avoir des migrants qui
ont une valeur et commerciaux notre vie
monsieur bernier
nous allons maintenant passer au face à
face aux suivis de débats les bras nous
allons commencer avec le chef du parti
conservateur monsieur adou chez vous
pouvez choisir la question que vous
voulez et la poser au chef que vous
souhaitez vous avez 30 secondes monsieur
trudeau vous avait contrevenu aux lois
sur les tic à deux reprises
vous êtes intervenu dans une affaire
dont les tribunaux ont été saisis vous
avez fermé les enquêtes sur votre
corruption et vous avez congédier les
deux seules personnes dans votre caucus
qui dénonçait vos actions simplement en
disant la vérité quand est ce que vous
avez décidé que les règles ne
s'appliquait pas à vous monsieur le rôle
d'un premier ministre et de se tenir
debout pour l'intérêt public et pour les
emplois des canadiens et canadiennes
c'est ce que j'ai fait ce que je
continue à faire chaque jour
la façon par laquelle j'ai travaillé
pour les canadiens c'est en investissant
pour eux voilà qui contrastait avec
votre vision
c'est à dire donner des réductions
d'impôts à ceux qui font quatre cent
mille dollars par année ou de ne plus se
déroule un poids ces gens qui font 400
mais plutôt que ceux qui font 40000 vous
offrir une réduction d'impôt de 50 mille
dollars
c'est plus que font bien des canadiens
ou 15 et les mines anti avec votre
programme électoral mais évidemment on
ne sait pas c'est quoi votre programme
parce que votre programme n'a pas de
couy dhabi jusqu'à présent griffith et
notre programme électoral publié depuis
des semaines nous avons travaillé avec
le directeur parlementaire du budget et
nous avons une vision qui mise de
l'avant qui différente de la vôtre parce
que nous décidons d'investir dans les
canadiens et les canadiennes
vous faites comme vos prédécesseurs vous
cachez votre programme des canadiens et
vous allez donner des crédits d'impôts
communaux
c'est à découper les services et les
autres chefs peuvent intervenir
également inventé ces choses-là de
toutes pièces la moitié de votre
plateforme et même pas chiffré vous
faites des annonces sans détails et sans
chiffres c'est vous vous mettiez au
quotidien comment vous allez qui calle
ces programmes là les taxes vont
augmenter il eut la classe moyenne
nous avons augmenté les impôts pour
l'heure pour ça que vous avez voté
contre soit vous avez regardé les
canadiens dans les yeux vous avez dit
que les allégations dans le groove et fo
vous avez dit que jodie webbot ne
s'étaient pas adressés à vous vous avez
dit que vous n'avez pas exercer de
pression sur elle ses mensonges
la responsabilité de tout premier
ministre est de protéger les emplois le
pdg de snc lavalin s'est adressé à vous
vous êtes entraîneur de chevaux en train
de se battre pour savoir lequel est le
pire pour le canada il faut commencer à
présenter qui sera le meilleur pour le
canada quand on pense à ce que les
canadiens vivent actuellement vos
petites réductions d'impôts monsieur je
ne devront pas les lesquels les
canadiennes et canadiens
à payer leurs soins de santé ou le coût
des médicaments qui peuvent coûter des
centaines de dollars par mois mais
canadien tim proposons et on veut leur
donner plus d'argent
on a d'abord c'est moi finir duction
dépôt pour nous allons faire économiser
de l'argent aux familles on va investir
dans les l'assurance médicament va
investir dans le service de garde
d'enfants
ça va permettre d'économiser des
centaines de dollars par mois aux
familles et les familles qui vont avoir
quand qu'il y en ait moins de 70 milles
par année vont avoir accès à des soins
dentaires ce qui va le faire économiser
1240 dollars par année
vous trouvez cela c'est toujours la même
question que les conservateurs ou
trouverez-vous l'argent
avec elle on va demander aux canadiens
canadiennes les plus riches ceux et
celles qui ont une fortune estimée à
plus de 20 millions $ de payer plus
d'impôts oui on croit qu'ils devraient
payer plus d'impôts vraiment fascinant
d'écouter ceux ci jack me fascine aux
propositions là parce que nous avons la
même proposition dans notre budget
lorsque le directeur parlementaire du
budget se pencher là dessus il est
quelle est la plus grande incertitude
lorsqu'une parlons de revenus des plus
riches
eh bien ils s'inquiètent que les cuirs
et chevron embaucher des avocats pour
éviter de payer ses impôts mais il faut
voir ce que le directeur parlementaire
du budget a dit parce que oui le quand
il avait dépensé beaucoup d'argent pour
les gares de lille pourrait venir
l'hekla scolarité pour l'assurance
médicaments mais bon si on dit qu'elle
ne fait presque un prêt passe parce
qu'il prêchait vont embaucher des
avocats pour éviter de payer leurs
impôts
mais c'est choquant n'est ce pas nous
sommes dans le plus beau pays au monde
ne donne en occident alors si vous êtes
riche vous avez cette obligation
vous avez la responsabilité de payer vos
impôts je me suis rien doit payer sa
juste part
je me souviens que messieurs chers a
déjà évoqué le scandale dessine si le
valais j'aimerais parler pour 3400
personnes innocentes qui n'ont rien fait
de mal lorsque monsieur trudeau a essayé
trouver une solution bien sûr et si les
prix de la mauvaise façon la demie mais
monsieur chien ce que vous faites c'est
que vous jouez votre vin tous là dessus
et vous non présente une idée que le
québécois est une province corrompue les
actions ont descendu les gens survie de
notre espèce
il ya des pertes à sofia cause de vous y
a pas d' excuses pour que le pr vénisse
interviennent mais dans une affaire dont
les tribunaux sont saisis
si quelqu'un ne devrait pas pouvoir
profiter de son poste et des ses amis
justement je veux je veux je veux
ajouter ajouté j'étais le seul chef qui
a dit qu'aucune entreprise ne peut être
au dessus des lois je suis le seul à
avoir tenu ces propos
je pense que c'est la seule chose qu'on
va se mettre d'accord
aucune grande entreprise respecte
aujourd'hui un bon début alors il semble
y avoir unanimité sur ce beau sujet
voilà qui conclut ce segment merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
je suis saison de l'accord du toronto
star
bienvenue au chef j'animerai le prochain
thème les questions autochtones
nous allons commencer ce segment du
débat choisis par tirage au sort de par
ma question ou conservés au chef du
parti conservateur a du chien
le voici monsieur nous avait dit qu'en
gouvernement conservateur se
concentrerait sur le concret dans ses
relations avec les peuples autochtones
du canada alors que vous poursuivez
votre corridor énergétique promis
comment allez vous concrètement
consulter accommoder et obtenir le
consentement du peuple autochtone et que
feriez vous lorsque vos plans entre en
conflit avec les droits et intérêts des
peuples autochtones g12 réserves des
premières nations dans ma
circonscription je reconnais
l'importance de tenir compte des droits
des issues du traité et du besoin pour
les peuples autochtones de participer à
l'économie canadienne
c'est la clé un gouvernement
conservateur
vous veillez à ce que sa proposition
pour un corridor énergétique tiennent
compte des préoccupations autochtone en
veillant à ce qu'un ministre du cabinet
soit responsable des consultations
autochtone
contrairement au jugement de la cour qui
a déterminé que le gouvernement actuel
n'avait pas correctement effectué les
consultations sur tmx
nous allons veiller à ce que les
consultations soient dynamiques nous
n'allons pas simplement cocher une case
nous allons tenir compte de ces
préoccupations légitimes mais il faut
également savoir qu'il nous faut pouvoir
réaliser de grands projets le devant de
consulter c'est d'entendre les
préoccupations des uns et des autres
mais il faut aussi que le projet voit le
jour
je trouve que c'est horriblement cher
que vous ayez oublié le devoir de
consulter c'est à la même chose pour le
gouvernement un peu eu aussi ont porté
atteinte bon
dans le cas des nuits enbridge comme
c'est le cas pour le pipeline trans
martin on n'a pas respecté la convention
des nations unies pour le droit des
peuples autochtones je sais qui vous
oppose à cette convention lors a déjà eu
le débat le débat mais clin d'oeil il
faut en dessous de l'article 35 de la
constitution il faut consulter les
populations autochtones et pas juste
pour faire en sorte qu'elles soient
d'accord avec nous il s'agit de
consultation nationale nation nous
parlons de droits territoriaux
qu'est ce que ça veut dire le
consentement prix alain breuils donner
librement qu'ils en veulent de ses
projets à mettre de côté cette décision
du tribunal des droits de la personne
pour porter cette question devant les
tribunaux comme un familier du dos alors
qu'ils ont conclue en fait que notre
gouvernement a agi contre les droits des
enfants autochtones
nous devrons visionnement des dizaines
de couches autochtone qui voudrait que
ces projets voient le jour parce qu'ils
savent que c'est le meilleur sur la
question ils savent que c'est comme ça
les jeunes vont prospérer
ça fait pas il faut qu'on ait définir ce
qu'on entend par le contenant pas l'avis
donné librement
monsieur blanchet vous le tour monsieur
je veux dire que vous vous les respectez
les champs de compétence des provinces
et du québec
mais quand il s'agit d'établir votre
corps et d'un mix énergétique qui se
traduit par pipeline si on veut à ce
moment là vous ne craignez pas
d'exproprier les gens dans toutes les
provinces
vous dites que la constitution vous
donne le droit de passer à travers les
provinces à travers le québec sans
l'approbation de la population
et je vous rappelle que le premier
ministre du québec et sa population sont
contre ces pipelines tout c'est faux il
est question de tenir compte des
préoccupations autochtone et des
préoccupations environnementales en
amont pour qu'on puisse enfin permettre
au grand projet de voir le jour
ces questions le contexte réglementaire
et vous le savez autant que moi
les québécois achètent beaucoup
d'énergie aux états unis je pense que
les québécois mais vous avez du vrai que
le québec de 18 h il faut pas de
l'énergie américaine c'est ce que j'ai
fait mon choix
monsieur bernier puis je vous rappeler
que l'on parle du respect des droits
autochtones au monsieur trudeau merci
nous nous rappelons le règne de dix ans
des seniors pour lequel il n'a pas
respecté les règles du droit autochtone
et les peuples autochtones et vous
monsieur scheer vous mettez de l'avant
exactement la même stratégie qui n'a pas
servi les peuples et les collectivités
autochtones et leurs enfants un plan en
vertu duquel le peut en fait pas de
projets énergétiques a été construit
nous devons respecter les peuples
autochtones ne vont respecter la
diversité d'opinion et le tout doit être
fondée sur les déclarations des nations
unies sur les droits des peuples
autochtones laquelle vous écartez par
l'entremise de vos actions ce n'est pas
respectueux des personnes autochtones
père burger qui est à la tête de
l'assemblée des premières nations a dit
qu'aucun gouvernement a davantage fait
pour les personnes autochtones que notre
gouvernement et il est temps de vous
comme étant monsieur chéri vous avez
raison il adorait vous parlez oui il va
vous appeler mon numéro de téléphone
moi je n'ai pas de leçons à tirer de
monsieur trudeau il a congédié la
première procureur général autochtone
pour avoir fait son travail elle dit
qu'elle ferait les choses différemment
et vous l'avait congédié
quand elle a justement fait les choses
différemment vous parlez de faire
construire des pipelines vous en avait
annulé 2 et celui que vous avez acheté
vous n'arrivez pas à le faire construire
vous avez déçus des dizaines de milliers
de personnes en alberta et en
saskatchewan et vous avez omis de
reconnaître que les communautés
autochtones à ris de veau décision parce
que je n'ai pas paniqué
d'après certains que parce que j'en ai
marre d'avoir d'autres dont parlerons
nous y reviendrons ce dernier vous avez
dit que vous étiez prêts à construire
des pipelines partout au pays
les laisser construire par le secteur
privé en parallèle vous avez dit que les
québécois étaient prêts à acheter du
pétrole et du gaz canadien je suis
d'accord avec vous parce que dickens les
québécois savent que c'est plus sûr de
transporter cela par pipeline que par
très mais en même temps le gouvernement
du québec lui a dit qu'il n'y avait pas
d'acceptabilité sociale pour la
construction de pipelines au québec
quelle est votre position
pensez vous que vous pourrez peut avoir
recours à la constitution parce que
après consultation qu'il n'y a pas
d'accord il faut pouvoir évoquer 92 10
de la constitution pour pouvoir
construire un pipeline
aurez-vous la compétence les pouvoirs
pour approuver cela vous dit oui je vais
construire des pipelines
mais allez vous avoir le courage honda
vol de recourir à la constitution pour
la prospérité l'unité du pays j'ai
toujours dit que le gouvernement fédéral
doit défendre sa compétence
nous respectons la compétence
provinciale quand on a la main l'idée et
je suis convaincu que je peux obtenir
l'adhésion de la population et que parce
que les québécois sont favorables à
l'énergie canadienne les québécois
savent que c'est mieux de consommer
d'énergie de l'ouest canadien que
d'avoir des pétroliers dans le fleuve
saint-laurent ou d'importer et de
l'énergie de notre shop et en plus on va
pouvoir laisser faire hachémi vibrer les
tribunes présente le tribunal des droits
de la personne du canada a conclu que le
gouvernement de monsieur trudeau a fait
preuve de discrimination envers les
enfants autochtones qui ne recevaient
pas un financement égal il ya eu une
décision qui dit que ces enfants
devraient avoir le même financement et
ensuite monsieur trudeau et son
gouvernement vont faire appel de cette
décision
il voulait travailler fort pour garder
snc lavalin ont des tribunaux mais il va
il va traîner ses enfants l'art
autochtone dans les tribunaux
ça fait c'est affreux comment peut-on
faire cela cette décision aurait des
implications profondes sur les services
de l'état à l'endroit des canadiens
autochtones
c'est un règlement très imposants et
quand il est question de politique
publique importante
c'est légitime de dire qu'il y à un
contrôle judiciaire
une autre chose on parle d'enjeux
autochtone je suis à la grèce et d'un
rose récemment une communauté bien sûr
qui est touché par un empoisonnement au
mercure et il ya eu une campagne de
levée de fonds privés et et monsieur
trudeau regza merci pour votre don
quels sites de premier ministre fait
cela j'aimerais bien avoir c'est une
réponse à votre question
non mais là tout le temps qui nous est
ce que pour cette partie du débat le
débat libre est terminée mais nous
poursuivons sur notre thème des affaires
autochtones nous avons une question d'un
membre de l'auditoire ici magath à
gatineau natacha bidet allez-y natacha
bonsoir en tant que membre de la
première nation beausoleil ma question
est la suivante si vous êtes élu comment
vos parties collaboreront t-il avec les
provinces et territoires sur la
reconnaissance et la réaffirmation des
droits autochtones notamment à la
lumière de la déclaration des nations
unies sur le droit de la personne
la commission de la vérité et de la
réconciliation et c'est un appel à
l'action et elle est la commission sur
les femmes autochtones et les femmes et
les filles autochtones disparues et
assassinées
merci pour votre question évidemment
difficile de répondre à cette question
là en 40 secondes dans ce rapport sur
les femmes et les filles autochtones
disparues et assassinées il ya beaucoup
de recommandations y compris lutter
contre la traite des personnes c'est
très important
de plus on soutient la protection des
langues autochtones
le gouvernement fédéral un rôle à jouer
pour protéger ces langues qui sont
menacées de disparition
on peut les préserver maintenant je
voudrais parler de la déclaration des
nations unies sur les droits des peuples
autochtones
quand il est question du consentement
préalable et donner librement
on ne sait pas exactement ce que ça veut
dire il ya beaucoup de communautés
autochtones qui veulent que ces projets
énergétiques soient réalisés il nous
faut plus de détails
il faut bien définir ce qu'on entend par
là d'accord nous passons maintenant
madame ait maigri tx7 une question
extrêmement importante que vous venez de
poser et tous les candidats du parti
version de l'os ou si nous allons
respecter la déclaration des nations
unies pour la protection des de la
protection des populations autochtones
nous allons les appliquer dans ce pays
on a parlé de des lois qui le présente
une violence structurelle dans la
capture des familles autochtones
disparues et assassinées il faut
absolument respecter cette déclaration
des nations unies
il faut respecter ces recommandations et
les appels à l'action de la commission
de vérité et de réconciliation scellée
par un projet à court terme nous les
canadiens colonisateur devons assurer la
justice également la déclaration des
nations unies
j'ai passé de bons moments au cours de
cette campagne avec des représentants
des peuples autochtones
ces peuples autochtones constituent des
nations tout comme le cannet le québec
au canada et donc il s'agit d'une
question de culture de langue de
patrimoine et qui se retrouvent dans les
mains d'une autre nation donc ils
doivent revendiquer ses droits
les représentent pas mieux qu'il pouvait
se représenter lui-même en dépit des
enquêtes et de toutes ces enquêtes qui
ont été fait auparavant
je me suis trop respectueux c'est fun
c'est ma nature de votre question nous
avons fait progresser la réconciliation
plus que tout autre gouvernement avant
nous mais je suis le premier à
reconnaître qu'il y reste encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire
nous avons levé 87 avis d'ébullition de
l'eau et les 50 qui reste vrai ça va se
faire ou si nous continuons à investir
dans les différentes collectivités
en ce qui a trait aux services aux
enfants aux familles nous reconnaissent
à nous reconnaissons que comme le dit
tribunal que les enfants doivent être
indemnisées ils seront indemnisés mais
nous allons aussi mettre fin à la
tragédie en faisant adopter des lois
pour que les enfants raison leur
collectivité avec leur langue leur
culture
nous allons améliorer les choses à green
arrow nous allons mettre de l'avant un
centre de traitement et nous aurons au
niveau nécessaire pour ça mais ce
dernier
notre chef est prêt à vraiment nous oui
de nouveau lié avec les premières
nations ils sont tous en faveur du statu
quo or le système actuel ne fonctionne
pas on continue à avoir des réserves
extrêmement pauvres
il faut une réforme vraiment courageuse
et notre parti est le seul qui va
justement accordé des droits de
propriété pour les résidents de réserve
et de mettre en place ce nouveau régime
d'autonomie pour ces communautés
il faut un nouveau système il faut
travailler avec les autochtones
mais les autres ne veulent pas et on ne
peut pas réparer le système sans une
réforme vraiment courageuse et nous nous
sommes et c'est merci natacha pour votre
question c'est une question de respect
et de dignité
tous les ans je vous avez soulevé
reviennent à cette question de respect
de dignité
une des premières choses que nous
ferions on ne prendrait on ne traînerai
pas les enfants autochtones devant les
tribunaux et contester une décision qui
fait suite à une discrimination
nous avons de riom immédiatement les
questions de justice qui veut dire
mettre en oeuvre toutes les
recommandations de rapport ces
recommandations puissante qui en
apportent des solutions jeu j'assurais
une eau potable propre on n'a pas d'
excuses je m'assurais d'un logement
propres de qualité une éducation et les
services d social on peut rien si jose
nous avons maintenant du temps pour un
autre débat en face-à-face sur n'importe
quel sujet et pour commencer et la chef
du parti vert est l'espèce mail vous
madame mais je crois que vous avez une
minute on a pendant des questions
autochtones et reconnaissons que
l'assemblée des premières nations nous
dit que leurs préoccupations prises par
la ce moment c'est l'urgence climatique
nous devons absolument nous concentrer
sur des solutions concrètes
vous ne pouvez pas avoir des plus belles
paroles que monsieur shihri avec tout le
respect qu'ils faisaient du monsieur
singh s'est pas seulement de beaux
discours ici il faut parler d'objectifs
et de sciences et pour ce faire il faut
l'idiot de 60% léger us d'ici 2030 près
de 28% par le club pour ça est-ce que
vous monsieur tu dois aller vous vous
joindre à nous mais dans un cabinet où
l'on met de côté la partisanerie un
cabinet ensemble ou dit que nous allons
agir ensemble pour protéger l'avenir de
nos enfants à marolles nous
reconnaissons que les cibles sont
importantes et nous allons les surpasser
ses objectifs mais l'essai bleus ne sont
pas un plan nous avons nous un plein qui
a livré la marchandise au cours des
quatre dernières années
nous allons sous peut bénir et interdire
les plastiques à usage unique
nous allons mettre en place un plan qui
retourne de l'argent dans les poches des
canadiens
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
chine la plupart des canadiens sont en
meilleure position grâce à cette
tarification de la pollution ça ne sera
pas le cas si lui il forme le gone
hommes après les élections et met au
rancart notre plan nous allons continuer
à faire ce qu'il faut faire pour que les
canadiens avancent nous avons un plan
réaliste ambitieux réalisables selon
besoin les canadiens parce que si on
n'agit pas sur les questions
environnementales et bien les
conséquences seront désastreuses ne pas
avoir un plan pour notre avenir
faire en sorte que ce sont des enfants
et d'amis subiront vous pouvez
maintenant lancer le débat libre
vous avez une trois minutes et 35
secondes les données scientifiques sont
claires votre objectif va mener à
l'échec mais c'est faisable nous pouvons
faire quelque chose vos objectifs ne
respecte pas les recommandations du giec
le génétique il faut s'éloigner des
combustibles fossiles et franchement
vous achetez un pipeline
vous ne pouvez pas être leader qui
défend le climat et vous dépenser des
milliards de dollars sur un projet qui
nous conduit qui je passe la drôme le
gard
nous avons un là nous avons pas
réalisable les canadiens ont besoin
qu'on agisse de façon elle nous mettrons
bien posture est nous qui nous permet de
lutter contre l'environnement de créer
une meilleure économie pour nos enfants
avec tous les respects autonome ont fait
davantage au cours des quatre dernières
années que non non non non non on va là
vingt parlementaires ayant de ce fait
refaire la personne ne se souvient du
plan de 2005 paul martens est nommé en
plein mais la réalité c'est ozil quatre
dernières années nous avons respecté la
naissance
il suffit pas de répéter quelque chose
ça veut pas dire que c'est vrai en
répétant qu'il est temps que vous
appreniez cela monsieur chiffre il n'y a
pas de canadiens qui pense qu'on aura
plus d'argent en payant une taxe carbone
vous avez des données de grande
extension aux plus grands émetteurs et
votre ventre et et j'ai déchiré tous ont
dit que 80 % des canadiens sont en
meilleure posture
en vertu de notre règle en fait
confiance à vos films vous ne voulez pas
agir par rapport aux changements
climatiques
vous avez promis de baisser les impôts
vous voulez mettre au rancart le seul
que nous avons voulu équilibrer le
budget voilà il ne me reste plus le
temps son plan est un échec à la fois
s'il vous plaît la vie coûte plus cher à
lui je veux dire quelque chose
directement canadiennes et canadiens
vous n'avez pas choisir entre monsieur
retardé monsieur déni il ya une autre
option qui existent nous sommes cinq
engageant un un vrai plein on va sévir
contre les grands pollueurs
il va falloir s'attaquer aux plus
puissants vous falloir qu'il est temps
les émissions mais le plus droitier qui
huaient décès
les des objectifs princier l'avenir des
enfants je veux je sais pas je veux dire
quelque chose
écoutez les canadiens doivent savoir que
monsieur trudeau et chiens ont la même
position ils veulent imposer une
tarification du carbone d'un côté ou
encore d'autres et d'autres la pire jeu
sur easy se sont mal alors vous êtes
semblable vous avez pu lire les gros
émetteurs vous avez la même position à
l'égard de ce dossier un terrain
d'entente
quand on sera à la chambre des communes
vous vous appuyer un projet qui encore
une fois dépasse le budget carbone et
vous imposer ce projet aux québécois un
projet qui viennent
j'ai déjà donné des réponses ce sujet
oui quand on prend cette idée de
péréquation basé sur les émissions de
ges ce qui dépasse la moyenne doivent
payer la péréquation et les autres qui
sont en dessous de l'avant pour faire
travailler ensemble avec tout le respect
qui vous a dit c'est la question que
j'ai posée monsieur trudeau est ce que
vous êtes prêts à accepter le changement
du statu quo qu'on change la façon de
plans de l'édition qu'on est au cabinet
interne était besoin de collaboration de
consensus et après c'est tout le temps
qu'il nous reste c'est à ces messieurs
où elle a tourné le temps qui nous reste
voilà qui termine cette partie des
débats merci beaucoup nous passons au
débat sur
[Musique]
bonjour je suis donne un freeze and o
globo news
je serai la modératrice pour le segment
sur le board habilité la sécurité du
revenu avant comment suis je dois dire
que vous avez été très animée dans vos
débats vos commentaires ont été un peu
long alors il faudra peut-être réduire
un peu le temps mais nous allons nous
assurer à ce que ce soit juste égal pour
tout le monde alors sur ce sujet madame
mais j'ai une question pour vous
la dette des ménages au canada se
chiffre à 2 trillions de dollars le
canadien moyen doit une standing pour
chaque dollar de revenu gagné après un
beau la dette n'a jamais été aussi élevé
nous empruntons pour les dépenses
communes de tous les jours
mes parents m'ont tous dit que ce n'est
pas une bonne idée madame med
comment elle et vous avez fait une
promesse audacieux soit de rééquilibrer
le budget en cinq ans pouvez vous y
arriver sans causer encore trop de
difficultés pour financièrement des
canadiens quelle sera votre politique
précis jazz qui permet à l'internaute de
déminage le parti de son parti zik et
qui a une bonne plate forme avec les
chiffres budgétaires notre plateau mais
chiffrés et dans le budget a été
approuvé par kevin ridge et son
l'institut pour la démocratie la seule
façon de mieux aider les canadiens donc
les les garderies on veut abolir les
frais de scolarité on veut investir dans
l'éducation post secondaire
il ya des programmes dentaire pour les
canadiens à faible revenu
l'assurance médicaments toutes ces
choses là ça pour rendre leur vie plus
abordable donc il faut avoir du revenu
ailleurs donc délais des paradis fiscaux
à l'étranger une taxe sur les
transactions financières une taxe de 1%
sur des personnes traction la fortune
pour les personnes qui ont plus de 20
millions de dollars de richesses alors
plusieurs mesures comme cela
profondément trash de revenu au
gouvernement du canada aurait bien sûr
ça d'après l'institut la situation
économique actuelle
si jamais il y avait
les sessions se sera pas une question
d'idéologie l'équilibré budgétaire mais
en ce moment oui on est censé monsieur
blanchet à vous d'en débattre avec
madame mais c'est vraiment une mauvaise
idée de emprunter pour payer l'épicerie
et ce n'est pas une meilleure idée que
de faire des compressions taupe
importante dans les services socialement
pour les gens qui en ont le plus besoin
on pourrait éliminer toute subvention
aux grandes pétrolières comme ce que
nous proposons faire grâce à un projet
de loi c'était faire et on en a discuté
pendant la question sur la péréquation
cela permettrait de renflouer les
coffres du gouvernement
qu'en est il des abris et fiscaux et
compris les deux nouveaux qui ont été
criés par monsieur trudeau et qu'on
essaie de percevoir des impôts des
gaffes d'accord oui absolument dans
notre plateforme
on veut imposer les géants du web amazon
google et facebook
ces entreprises qui attire des millions
de dollars dans ce pays sans payer
d'impôts et nous sommes d'accord avec
vous il faut cesser de subventionner les
combustibles fossiles c'est une promesse
qui a été faite mais c'est tout le
contraire on a fait davantage de
subventions pour le gnl
j'aimerais bien vous entendre parler un
peu de gnl québec on restait palace
également tous les combustibles fossiles
au visage subies par on est encore à
fond et je dois vous intéresse
monsieur trudeau à vous d'en débattre
avec madame mais sur la dette des
ménages
lorsque nous avons décidé d'investir
dans les canadiens plutôt que lui et
cette décision des vaisseaux dans les
classes moyennes et investit aussi dans
ceux qui veulent se joindre la classe
moyenne a permis de sortir 900 mille
personnes pauvreté inclure trois cent
mille enfants nous avons investi dans
plus d'étudiants pour qu'ils puissent
aller à l'école va baisser dans les
personnes âgées et grâce à cela nous
avons fait croître notre économie plus
d'un million de nouveaux emplois ont été
créés la plupart d'entre eux a tenté au
cours des quatre dernières années
en même temps nous avons réduit la
pauvreté et nous avons surpassé toutes
les cibles qui avait été mise de l'avant
nous l'avons fait de façon responsable
les agences de quitter la nationale ont
donné une cote de crédit triple a cédé
la parole à madame mais dans tous les
débats et je suis certain que d'autres
chefs ici sont inquiets on a on n'a pas
le temps pour parler des soins de santé
et des coûts des soins de santé dans ce
débat alors je veux que nous parlions de
la question de la potabilité la vie
devra être plus abordable pour les
canadiens si on avait une religion
universelle d'assurance médicaments
c'est dans la traque forme ça dans la
plate forme de missions civiles il m'a
fait ça pour des soins de santé ont
baissé le coût des médicaments ou même
voler ses universités désolé mais c'est
tout le temps dont vous disposez à vous
d'en débattre monsieur bernier tout à
fait tout à fait écouter regarder votre
programme je l'examiné et des années 60
milliards de dollars c'est ce que vous
allez lui dépensé sans créer de
richesses on ne peut pas créer la
prospérité à partir de rien il faut que
le secteur privé sentir et investissent
on sait que nous avons encore des
difficiles
monsieur trudeau vielles d'ajouter 17
milliards de dollars à la dette et vous
vous allez ajouter 60 milliards écoutez
c'est irresponsable
ce sont nos enfants qui vont payer la
note dans le secteur privé lorsque vous
étiez le cabinet de monsieur repris il
ya eu des réductions fiscales pour les
grandes entreprises on l'a dit ça la clé
des emplois mais ces grandes entreprises
n'ont pas investi dans l'économie sont
assis sous des piles d'argent et c'est
de l'argent qui n'a pas investi ça ne
sert à rien alors il faut mettre la main
sur cet argent là pour investir dans un
réseau national du cirque aux gens de
faire bouger d'électricité d'une
quantité pays à l'autre sans pipe line
il nous faut se réseauter le christ et
pour desservir des besoins de toutes les
provinces
ce que je me dis
c'est que vous ne voulez pas de
subvention pour l'industrie du gaz et du
pétrole et moi je ne crois pas aux oies
c'est des cadeaux de ce genre vous
vouliez changer la discussion vers les
soins de santé c'est un une des
préoccupations principales les
canadiennes et canadiens ne veux pas
avoir accès aux médicaments dont ils ont
besoin aux soins dentaires dans mon
bureau à ben ali
j'ai une dame qui est venue elle était
gêné parce qu'elle avait perdu des dents
en raison d'un manque de soins qu'elle
ne pouvait pas se permettre ça c'est ça
me brise le coeur
madame sy vous êtes prête à le faire le
problème c'est que monsieur trudeau n'a
pas le courage de s'attaquer aux
lobbyistes de l'industrie pharmaceutique
un mois je vais le faire si vous votez
pour les néo démocrates
on va s'assurer que ça se passe on
travaille pas pour les riches et pour
les grandes sociétés
on travaille pour vous on travaille pour
les canadiennes et canadiens on va vous
livrer la marchandise
il faut re négocié un nouvel accord de
santé c'est un accord que l'on n'a pas
touché depuis trop longtemps
il faut revenir à la table dans ma
circonscription bon je viens de débattre
à l'échelle locale vous fait tout ça
pour vous monsieur blanchir je n'avais
pas de candidat mais la plupart d'entre
vous avait d'excellents candidats ma
circonscription j'ai été battu avec lui
cette semaine sont excellent candidat
mais s'il ya une chose que nous avons
tous entendu ce que nous souffrons il
n'y a pas suffisamment de médecins de
famille il faut investir dans les soins
de santé
ça ne fonctionne pas en ce moment il
faut investir chez eux à vous la
possibilité d'un débat la question porte
sur le coût de la vie et l'endettement
des ménages
le thème principal de notre plateforme
c'est de donner plus d'argent aux
canadiens c'est qu'ils en aient plus
dans leurs poches
notre baisse d'impôts universelle va
donner 852 $ de plus dans un proche d'un
couple moyens on voit également des
taxes et les prestations de maternité on
un crédit d'impôt pour le transport en
commun et on a également un crédit
d'impôt pour les rénovation
écoresponsable
mission pas du tout ça c'est tout le
contraire voici comment on va payer
nous voulons réduire l'aide
internationale du canada de 25% on va
cesser d'envoyer de l'argent aux pays
qui sont bien nantis
on veut ramener cet argent-là au canada
pour que les canadiens puissent
améliorer leur situation
votre plateforme inexistante
l'idée de sabrer dans l'aide au
développement
donc c'est sur ip une lettre que j'ai
représenté s'agit de développement
durable de l onu il faut mettre fin à la
pauvreté au canada et à l'échelle
internationale c'est quelque chose que
nous pouvons faire de la prochaine
décennie
on ne pourra jamais y arriver si nous
avons je pense que l'argent mais si la
course est pas un égoïste de mettre
l'argent dans les poches du stage à
mende les portes vous intéresse
nous avons un terrain où que nous
puissions attendre un autre canadien sur
le thème de l'abordabilité un endroit où
on nous écoute ce soir est taillée
l'onef dans les territoires du
nord-ouest
voici ce qui se passe au restaurant
cobra hausse nous avons entendu une
question sur l'abordabilité du score
martin un peu plus tôt bonjour mon nom
au score marseille niall o 9
la question des suivantes que fera votre
parti au chap et de l'inégalité de
revenus de l'abordabilité au pays et je
suis déjà bien ça restera là bonsoir
yellowknife je suis ravi de vous voir à
nouveau il faut absolument agir pour le
l'équité du revenu l'écart entre les
riches et le canadien moyen continue de
se creuser
nous demandons par une commission sur la
fiscalité n'y a pas de bonnes commission
sur la fiscalité depuis les années 60 il
faut cette commission qui se penche sur
le code fiscal pour moi c'est un code
fiscal qui est toujours un progressif
il faut éliminer c'est ces allègements
fiscaux pour les grandes entreprises et
faire en sorte que ce soit les canadiens
qui en ont le plus besoin qui s est
revenu et
les canadiens les mieux narcy bon
plusieurs villes 14 général ont constaté
que l'agencé de revenu du canada les
têtes comme s'ils n'ont pas de femmes
mlf plancher comme s'ils ont un statut
spécial
je dois dire que si le fait de dire des
faussetés les répéter et bien bien des
entreprises feraient face à des
problèmes un autre enjeu si le
gouvernement fédéral veut respecter les
champs de compétence des provinces
cela permettrait d'accélérer les choses
il se serait moins coûteux et les
provinces comme le québec pourrait faire
ce qu'elles doivent faire en matière de
santé c'est à dire de rendre au québec
l'argent qui lui est dû
il faut aider les provinces donc donné
l'argent aux provinces comme le québec
parce que c'est essentiellement leur
champ de compétences et ainsi compléter
la population la question pas sur
l'inégalité de revenus
est-ce que vous faire nous reconnaissons
que nous devons aider plus directement
les gens c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons d'emblée réduit les impôts de
la classe moyenne et augmenter les
impôts des milandes si nous allons de
l'avant avec une autre réduction d'impôt
pour les canadiennes de classe moyenne
et pour ceux qui font moins d'argent il
n'y aura pas de réduction d'impôt pour
ceux qui font plusieurs genres
contrairement à monsieur scheer nous
allons aussi aller de l'avant avec la
location quinzaine pour enfants qui va
être bonifiée grâce à laquelle aussi
bien des gens sont sortis de la pauvreté
dans l'augmenter 50% les enfants de
moins d'un an de l'umci bonifier les
sécurités vieillesse ou pour ceux qui
ont plus de 65 ans et nous allons aussi
nous assurer que les étudiants puissent
plus facilement repayer leurs dettes
d'études et ils n'auront pas à payer
tant qu'ils ne pensent qu'à leur
pardonner gagner avoue tout d'abord je
crois qu'il est important d'être en
mesure de discuter de ce qui est
vraiment important pour le canadien or
nous sommes le seul parti qui va
équilibrer en deux ans le budget du pays
tous les autres partis ici représenté
vaut se contenter de dépenses et de
dépenser ce n'est pas la solution
nous on va atteindre cet objectif sans
s'attaquer aux services évidemment les
subventions aux entreprises ça
disparaîtra 5 milliards de dollars qu'on
va économiser
les autres partis ne font que vous
cotisez pour obtenir votre vote
moi je vous promets d'équilibrer le
budget c'est tout après quoi
après quoi on baissera les impôts c'est
la seule police vers merci monsieur
seigner vous je veux à merci scott pour
sa question l'inégalité des revenus est
un problème majeur
on ne parle pas seulement de discussion
universitaire ou théoriques
quand les gens quand 87 familles au
canada on la richesse combinée de trois
provinces sa nuit aux familles ça veut
dire qu'on n'a pas les fonds nécessaires
pour investir dans les soins de santé on
peut pas investir dans les soins
dentaires
monsieur trudeau il parle bien je
l'admets mais ce qu'il a fait il a donné
14 milliards de dollars aux sociétés les
plus riches pour qu'elles puissent
acheter des avions privés et des
limousines
nous on suggère d'investir dans les gens
demandaient aux super riches de payer
leur juste part et investir dans des
programmes pour alléger le fardeau
grassi monsieur à vous parler de
l'inégalité de ruffier
monsieur trudeau se trompe de nouveau
notre baisses d'impôts universelle c'est
beaucoup mieux pour les canadiens de la
classe moyenne que ses propositions à
lui il pense que quelqu'un qui gagne 47
mille dollars par année est trop riche
pour une baisse d'impôts je suis en
désaccord
on n'est pas obligés d'abaisser les
autres pour eux ou pour en rehausser
d'autres encore il faut qu'on donne de
nouvelles perspectives aux canadiens
pour qu'ils puissent augmenter leurs
revenus
monsieur trudeau a cherché à protéger
ceux qui ont hérité des fiducie nous
allons avoir une approche pratique et
que les entrepreneurs et le soutien
ainsi son besoin salon parce que j'ai
passé à autre chose une question pour le
leader du bloc québécois monsieur yves
françois blanchet après quoi il pourrait
en débattre monsieur blanchet le québec
est une de ses provinces qui reçoit des
paiements de péréquation en 2010 mais
apple a reçu 13 milliards de dollars
c'est la somme la plus élevée de toutes
les provinces où la richesse et partagez
vous avez dit que c'est de l'aide
sociale le provenant du reste du canada
le premier ministre françois legros a
dit qu'il veut éliminer la dépendance à
ces paiements de péréquation
êtes vous d'accord et comment lorsque la
fera-t-il que la vie soit pierre bordas
cours les canadiens les systèmes de
régulation est fondée sur un faux
raisonnements une fausse façon de façon
erronée d'analyser les choses et on
pourrait le remplacer par un autre
système toutes les provinces sont très
riches ils ont développé leurs
ressources avec de l'argent provenant de
partout au canada y compris le québec
est à ce jour s'en servent pour menacer
le québec et les québécois ne veulent
pas que le pétrole passe par leur
territoire parce qu'ils ont confiance en
l'énergie propre
nous proposons un type de péréquation
qui
pourrait se faire sans changement la
constitution ainsi on pourrait
contribuer à lutter contre les
changements climatiques et que ceux qui
sont au dessus de la moyenne en matière
de js doivent payer les provinces qui
ont sont sous la moyenne tension que les
réduire les échanges et r6 l'occasion
d'en débattre face à face nous
commençons avec beaucoup de minutes
la péréquation existe pas que tous
canadiens où qu'ils vivent puissent
avoir accès aux mêmes services de même
qualité partout pays ce n'est pas un
système parfait mais c'est un système
qui assure dans la mesure du possible
que tous aient les mêmes chances ou
qu'ils soient canada nous continuons à
dialoguer avec les provinces partout au
pays pour mettre à jour la formule de
péréquation de façon juste et c'est
quelque chose qui nous unit
malheureusement malheureusement monsieur
blanchet en tant que souverainiste
vous êtes à la recherche de moyens par
lesquels vous pouvez utiliser des
tensions entre le québec et le reste du
canada pour faire progresser vos idées
malheureusement ce n'est pas ce que les
canadiens veulent quand vous achetez un
pipeline et dites moi que peuvent faire
les canadiens bien par définition un
québécois pu faire tout ce qu'elle peut
faire parce qu'un québécois et aux
canadiens et demeurera c'est un canadien
tant que je serai le lycée mais ce
dernier avoue maintenant débattre avec
monsieur blanchet puisqu'il est question
de péréquation je suis le seul chef de
parti qui soit prêt se pencher sur la
formule de péréquation afin de s'assurer
que la formule sera plus équitable est
moins généreuse plus équitable pour
toutes les provinces
je m'explique ce n'est pas juste de
taxer les gens de l'ouest et du québec
parce que les québécois sont fiers et
québécois
vivre dans une province plus riches donc
ce qu'il faut faire c'est trouver les et
c'est hâtif permettant à chaque port est
de développer ses ressources naturelles
c'est important d'en discuter du dossier
de la péréquation or ici les autres ne
veulent pas en parler donc soyons
généreux soyons et qui tarde le portent
tous pourquoi parce que quand on pose la
question quand on pose la question aux
libertés 20 des gens veut lever pour
cent des gens veulent en parler
québécois
j'en appellerai euros par personne
d'argent qui par anita au canada par le
biais de l'application que tous les
autres clans karité de regarnir ses
postiers blanche et monsieur saigne à
vous d'en débattre
oui je réfléchisse à des façons de
rendre la vie plus abordable et je pense
qu'on pourrait travailler ensemble avoir
de meilleurs résultats
je pense qu'on peut bâtir un meilleur
canada si on s'attaque aux défis
auxquels sont confrontés les gens au
québec vous avez le coût des soins de la
santé qui sont très élevés sont
travailler ensemble avec un régime
d'assurance médicament universel et ça
pourrait être offert par les provinces
et ont pour on aurait des coûts plus bas
mais provincialement nous avons les
soins dentaires
le crs on voulait le financer ce serait
un champ de compétence provinciale vous
avez une bonne idée mais vous voulez
toujours intervenir empiéter sur les
champs de compétence des provinces
si vous voulez agir ainsi mais qui est
il faut le faire pour l'ensemble du
canada mais nous on veut que l'argent
soit renvoyer quelque chose qui pour
venir mais la constitution vous attaquer
au problème du logement le logement ça
préoccupe beaucoup de gens l'argent
fédéral était investi auparavant pour
construire des logements on réfléchit
non merci ou plutôt monsieur cm
monsieur chien à vous la parole
vous mélangez l'a écouté j'ai durement
range aujourd'hui là c'est par exprès qu
est ce que je devrais faire mais je suis
un petit peu plus grand que vous hein
c'est important que lis que les
québécois reconnaissent que monsieur
blanchet est d'accord avec monsieur
trudeau sur beaucoup d'enjeux il
soutient les déficits massifs qui vont
exercer des pressions sur les
contribuables québécois parce que le
service de la dette coûte de plus en
plus cher augmente il ya quelque chose
n'avait pas compris nous savons que la
priorité de monsieur blanchet c'est
travailler avec le parti québécois pour
obtenir la souveraineté un vote pour un
député du bloc québécois
ça veut dire que monsieur trudeau va
rester premier ministre
tout ce que vous dites que ça a été fait
lorsque c'est un gouvernement
minoritaire à l'âge des changements
715,6 te suit les noms je voulais
soutenir l'économie américaine
moi je prie pas que je vais faire cette
chance de riez vous vous êtes arrêté
vous n'avez plus de temps madame est à
votre tour
non non bonjour je vous voilà j'aimerai
vous féliciter d'avoir été élu député à
l'échelle du territoire
alors bon si on part de la péréquation
nous avons besoin de la péréquation au
canada puisque nous sommes un pays qui
agit comme une famille alors il faut
passer comme une famille monsieur
blanchet est ce que vous proposez c'est
de mettre un fardeau supplémentaire sur
certaines parties du pays comme
l'alberta où ce serait difficile pour
eux de respecter les objectifs de la
crise climatique
le parti vert vu que nous travaillons
tous ensemble ne parlera pas l'alberta
étant donné que vos prises de position
pour ce qui est du pétrole étaient les
leurs
capable si 2030 je ne fais pas que c'est
les gentils ve
on n'est pas toujours d'accord avec les
autres membres et on ne doit pas forcer
certains membres souhaiteraient passer
devant ce cru matic ici vous conseiller
sur ce que les scientifiques disent
elles seulement
oui c'est une question mondiale et c'est
grâce au pays oui c'est une affaire
absolument agir ni province favori
nation nous devons tous travailler
ensemble ils doivent passer à autre
chose merci
nous allons terminer ce segment avec un
autre débat libre monsieur blanchet à
votre tour de poser une question chef de
votre choix sur le sujet de votre choix
eh bien monsieur vous avez dit en
anglais il ya quelques mois que vous
étiez contre l'idée du projet de loi 21
sur la cyclicité de l'état au québec
ensuite vous avez dit en français au
québec que vous ne juriez pas pour
contrer cette loi mais votre
collaborateur monsieur meyer reyes a dit
il y a deux jours que vous alliez
protéger le projet de loi 21 l'a dit en
français je dois l'admettre et vous
étiez le seul qui allait protéger la
terre comment allez vous vous y prendre
c'est très sain monsieur blanchet vous
le savez on a toujours été clair nous
les conservateurs le sujet nous n'allons
pas intervenir dans cette affaire dont
les tribunaux sont saisis les élus du
québec ont pris une décision et
maintenant les tribunaux sont saisis et
la cour va rendre son jugement
je les ai toujours dit à la fois en
anglais et en français
c'est important que le gouvernement
fédéral respecte et protège les libertés
individuelles et les droits de la
personne nous n'allons pas intervenir
dans ce schéma la parole c'est très
simple je viens de répondre à votre
question fut blanchet c'est monsieur
chez eux qui a la parole j'ai répondu en
français aussi nous n'allons pas
intervenir dans cette affaire les
tribunaux ans ont saisi que tu monsieur
réel s'il vous contredit non ma position
est la même
vous essayez de semer la confusion là où
il y en a pas entre la loi ça ne veut
pas dire que vous allez me protéger moi
je la protégerai alors vous nous allons
maintenant voir débat libre c'était le
temps imparti à monsieur nous allons
maintenant avoir un débat libre monsieur
blanchet vous pouvez commencer puisque
valise dont paul tout à l'heure au
calaisis la question est la même depuis
le tout début
monsieur blanchet j'ai l'impression que
vous essayez de créer une confusion là
où il y en a pas
j'ai toujours été très clair à la fois
en anglais et en français ma réponse a
toujours été la même à l'échelle
fédérale le parti conservateur a
toujours défendu les libertés
individuelles les droits fondamentaux
des droits la personne c'est un premier
ministre conservateur qui a présenté une
déclaration des droits la personne
s'était dit fils d'école parce que trait
aux protections lgbt cul non si vous
n'avez pas non plus vous ne vous êtes
pas non plus excuser pour les mots que
vous avez proféré le gardien canadien et
qu'elle reconnaisse que vous avez des
chutes futur il ya des millions de
canadiens qui ont un avis différent sur
cette question là et comme des millions
de canadiens
je suis personnellement prouvy on peut
avoir une autre et qui ont doté les
canadiens doivent savoir si le chercher
même démoniser se livre à la fois s'il
vous plaît à la fois les lois sur
l'accès dans sur cette question n'ont
pas changé ni sous un gouvernement
conservateur lee souhaite vraiment
illégal et celui tremplin ministre allez
vous défendre les femmes permettant à m
sinda prend l'essentiel voc vous signer
des pétitions
les gens qui veulent retirer les droits
des femmes mais qu'est ce qui est arrivé
en nouvelle écosse avec votre candidat
or you know
écouter personne ne peut entendre ce que
vous dites vous avez permis des
candidats oui je sais que vous êtes en
train d'avoir un mini débat n'en a aucun
aucune place dans une discussion sur le
droit des femmes à choisir est claire là
dessus c'est vraiment un coup est
intéressant dans cette campagne on
entendu les hommes se chicaner sur les
droits des femmes mais vous tout ça pour
enfants max qui a participé aux débats
de tva et vous étiez ravi la d'exclure
les femmes je suis la seule chef femme
de partie je peux et je n'étais pas là
vous avez participé à un débat où on n'a
pas pu dire ou jeunes filles qu'elles
ont la chance de devenir premier
ministre que d'être le chef d'un parti
soyons clair il faut être clair nous
tous comme chez vous un jo vous n'êtes
pas clair lorsque vous dites que vous
n'allez jamais permettre que l'on vous
n'êtes pas de là que vous allez défendre
les droits des femmes et des filles dans
ce pays se voient pour lesquels on s'est
battu j'avais fait que vous soyez
ils vont prendre députés pourraient
soulever un projet de loi présenté après
je ne vois là contre l'avortement
on n'est pas mais alors il nous faudrait
certainement plus tard malheureusement
c'est tout le temps dont nous disposons
madame merci beaucoup
nous allons devoir passer le sujet
direct merci
voilà qui courent une autre séquence
[Musique]
bonjour je suis heureux même quand une
de ces décennies notre prochain thème
nous en avons déjà parmi quelque peu et
maintenant nous ne l'abandonnerons pas
de vrais l'environnement et l'énergie
nous commençons par une question d'un
autre canadien nous allons passer un
groupe de personnes qui nous regardent
cette fois-ci de la bibliothèque
centrale de halifax
je vais parler abrite une bankroll de
menthe au nouveau brunswick il à la
question suivante
bonjour je m'appelle je viens de
manteaux au nouveau brunswick
je crois que nous vivons dans un état de
crise climatique et nous en sommes à la
dernière élection avant le point de
non-retour peu plus j'estime que les
grandes entreprises à qui polluent
considèrent que le système actuel de
réglementation et d'amandes et nick rien
de plus que le coup de faire affaire
quel plan concret chaque leader chaque
chef était là pour contrer la pollution
des comptes entreprises merci la
première est question la première
réponse à monsieur blanchet ce qui est
considéré comme le système le plus
progressif pour lutter contre les jurés
c'est cette entente entre la californie
le québec cette bourse du carbone qui
force les entreprises à réduire leurs
émissions au fil du temps et cela
fonctionne très bien et j'ai eu le
privilège de mettre au point ces
négociations et de les mener à bien les
signer l'entente
le fait est que en retour de l'argent si
on perd tout temps nous remettre
l'argent dans les poches des
contribuables
ça ne fait rien on espère que le
saint-esprit viendra se plaindre mais
trudeau
monsieur blanchet le québec tout comme
d'autres provinces comme un conte bureau
technique à 10,6 de terrifier le carbone
nous nous sommes assurés que cette
édification s'étend à l'échelle du pays
parce que c'est un mécanisme qui va un
rideau les émissions et 2 assurer que
les canadiens peuvent se permettre cette
transition le choix ce soir est clair il
est entre deux parties qui ont des
visions fort différente du changement
climatique
monsieur scheer
veut mettre au rancart le seul plan
c'est le chemin sur les changements
climatiques que nous ayons eue après
qu'il serait élu et nous nous
reconnaissons qu on doit faire davantage
ces changements climatiques c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous allons
dépasser surpasser nos objectifs et on
espère y arriver ou 9 0 d'ici 2050 si
populaire le seul parti vraiment
environnementalistes pourquoi parce que
nous nous voulons faire des choses qui
sont réalistes qui sont possibles pour
protéger l'air pour protéger
l'environnement pour protéger l'eau tous
les autres chefs prétend sauver la
planète sauver le climat
c'est impossible le canada ne
représentent que 1,6 pour cent des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sur la
planète on on nous dit on va atteindre
les cibles de l'accord de paris c'est
fou ils ne peuvent pas il faudrait une
taxe de 300 dollars par tonne or ils ne
sont pas prêts à imposer cette taxe sont
des hypocrites
vous avez terminé mais ce signe merci
but pour votre question on est confronté
à une crise climatique et aucun d'autres
qui a des gays des feux de forêt majeur
qui rendent la respiration difficile
dans certaines régions du pays vous avez
des inondations les gens qui voient les
gens perdent leur leur habitation c'est
une crise grave
bon monsieur trudeau a dit plusieurs
belles choses regardons ce qu'il a fait
il a dit qu'il est pour l'environnement
et continue d'exhorter les grands
pollueurs
il dit qu'il a il veut s'attaquer aux
grands pollueurs et continue à
subventionner les free gazière et
pétrolière
et il dit que tout leader
environnemental qu'est ce qu'il fait il
achète un oléoduc
il y a un immense fossé entreprises ici
il fait ses chiens je suis de nouveau
d'accord avec vous monsieur singh a au
sujet de l'environnement monsieur
trudeau dit une chose est en fait une
autre il parle décide de 2050 il peut
même pas atteindre l'iss et de 2030
il parle d'un véritable plan mais son
plan est un échec ça déjà été prouvée il
a donné de grands d'exonération plus
grands émetteurs et ses grands émetteurs
ont pu négocier une exemption à eau
de 90% de sa taxe carbone et pendant ce
temps là les travailleurs canadiens
les femmes les parents ils emmènent
leurs enfants à l'école et eux sont
obligés d'assumer l'ensemble la taxe
carbone nous voulons que la lutte sur
les changements climatiques soit une
lutte mondiale manami de cette question
vous contrairement à tous les autres ici
avec moi vous compreniez que nous sommes
aux prises avec une vraie crise
climatique
le gie est que le groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat nous a donné des objectifs ce
serait difficile de les atteindre
certainement on ne peut pas dire que bon
parce que notre plan est un peu moins
ambitieux ça veut dire kick c'est
faisable non non il faut absolument
atteindre la cible
il faut absolument limiter le
réchauffement planétaire à ou plus 1,5
degré celsius au dessus du niveau de
référence
sinon nos enfants n'auront pas un monde
où il fait bon vivre
la tête une balle a raison lorsqu'elle
dit que notre maison est en feu alors il
faut sauver les enfants et nous allons
sauver les âmes en temps de poser une
question celle ci s'adresse à monsieur
trudeau et c'est la question suivante
l'automne dernier le panel lecomte
expert international intergouvernemental
sur l'évolution du climat privé prévient
que nous devons agir vite pour éviter le
changement le réchauffement climatique
et un rapport d'environnement canada
indique que le canada se réchauffe deux
fois plus vite que la moyenne mondiale
vous dites vouloir combattre le
changement climatique et pourtant votre
gouvernement fera néanmoins acheter
approuvé un nouvel oléoduc vers la côte
ouest
étant donné le délai est dangereuse en
cause le canada ne devrait ne devrait-il
pas tourner le dos à l'exploitation du
gaz et du pétrole et à cette fin le
programme d'agrandissement du thermique
serait t'il être le dernier projet et de
l'ird et il ment
agir rapidement nous devons faire plus
ces raisons pour lesquelles nous avons
mis de l'avant un plan ambitieux pour
continuer sur notre lancée un plan
réalisable un plan en vertu duquel nous
allons nous assurer non seulement ne
soit pas si nos cibles de 2030
mais aller au delà de cela nous allons
interdire les plastiques à usage unique
nous ont terrifié la pollution et nous
luttons contre les premiers ministres
conservateurs qui ne veulent pas perdre
je sois pas pour lutter contre les
changements climatiques nous
reconnaissons que la transition vers
l'énergie verte ne sera pas en un
claquement de doigts ce que nous devons
faire c'est avoir moins de pétrole qui
transitent par rail nous devons arriver
à parvenir à de nouveaux marchés pour
pouvoir investir tout l'argent qui
découlent de ce pipeline dans cette
transition verte dans cette lutte contre
les changements climatiques
je sais que ça fait partie de la
solution pour l'avenir pour comment nous
allons investir dans l'avenir dans cette
transition et voilà ce que nous avons
fait jusqu'à présent le choix ce soir il
suivant est ce qu ont choisi un
gouvernement qui ne croit pas au
changement climatique et dans la lutte
contre ces changements ou est ce qu'on
continue sur la même voie répondu à la
dernière partie de la question ceux
concernant laine dernier monsieur
bernier monsieur trudeau on est d'accord
pour dire que nous sommes un désaccord
pas ce qui concerne le changement
climatique vous dit qu'il ya une crise
moi je ne crois pas cela et de toute
façon vous ne serez pas en mesure
d'atteindre les cibles de l'accord de
paix dit si l'onu qu'il dit vous voulez
poser une taxe carbone de 300 dollars
par tonne ni vous n'avez pas le courage
de le faire
vous ne faites pas terminée et disait tu
as raison
évidemment elle est radicale elle a un
plan qui détruirait l'économie pour la
planète mais vous en quatre ans nous
avons atteint 75% de nos objectifs de
2030 alors au cours des deux prochaines
années nous allons arriver à notre cible
en plantant deux milliards d'armes et
monsieur banny ce que vous ne comprenez
pas ce que monsieur le chien ne comprend
pas non plus et que vous ne pouvez pas
avoir un plan pour l'avenir de notre
économie si vous n'avez pas un plan qui
protègent l'environnement et qui lutte
contre les changements climatiques
et c'est là où vous deux
vous allez vous fais ton truc à votre
cas vous deux je sais que vous dites de
très belles choses devaient décrire
chose aujourd'hui à la tribune
le problème c'est que vous avez des
idées plusieurs des mêmes choses en 2015
et vous avez dit que vous feriez de des
enjeux climatiques quelque chose
d'important mais vous continuer de
subventionner l'industrie gazière
pétrolière
vous avez acheté un oléoduc qu'est-ce
qui va falloir pour que les canadiennes
et canadiens vous croira crois que vous
avez respecté vos promesses
parce que vos paroles ne tiennent pas la
route nous avons atteint 75% de nos
cibles de 2030 selon surpasser ses
objectifs les canadiens seront peut-être
surpris de découvrir monsieur signe que
votre plan est le suivant vous allez
construire une raffinerie de grande
envergure en alberta et comment
allez-vous faire ça avec des subventions
canadienne votre plan de construction de
raffineries en alberta et pire pour
l'environnement que de construire un
pipeline qui va vers le gouverneur est
pas du tout j'ai pas notre place nous on
mettrait fin immédiatement aux
subventions on investir immédiatement
d'enrichir c'est à vous détendre quand
justin trudeau a pris le pouvoir il y
avait trente trois grands projets
pipelinier qui était déjà prêt mais les
trois ont échoué il le prit 4,5
milliards de dollars de l'argent des kew
contribuables pour le projet jones
mountain il a pris 4,5 millions de
dollars de l'argent des contribuables
aux états unis pour que cet argent soit
investi dans le secteur pétrolier gazier
là bas il a deux avions de campagne et
il a acheté des compensations
environnementales que sushi reçu trudeau
monsieur trudeau je suis répondre
monsieur chien
monsieur vous n'avez pas acheté de
crédits carbone pour votre transport
durant la campagne parce que vous croyez
on ne vous entend agir de façon
responsable monsieur chiffre est votre
plan c'est le déchirer carrément le seul
plan sérieux pour la lutte contre les
changements climatiques et le canada
votre temps s'est écoulé monsieur trenet
mandat mais a fait d'éviter
réchauffement climatique catastrophique
il faut absolument d'oublier les cibles
actuelles il faut écouter les
scientifiques
on ne peut pas construire le pipeline
trans partis ne sera pas le dernier il
faut il faut les annuler si nous sommes
sérieux
on ne peut pas négocié avec la physique
vous comme premier ministre le vous
comme chef du parti libéral vous ne
pouvez pas négocier avec ça il ya un
budget carbone et il n'y a aucune
flexibilité dans ce budget carbone
voilà pourquoi ça me fait mal de vous
voir aujourd'hui de savoir que j'aurais
pu aller encore plus loin il ya quatre
ans j'espère que vous n'avez pas de
majorité cette fois ici parce que
j'allais faire respecter vos promesses
jusqu'à la baie de fundy les conserver
les premiers ministres conservateurs ont
été élus en promettant de ne rien faire
ce changement climatique dans les
provinces qui il faut un gouvernement
fédéral fort pour lutter contre eux pour
s'assurer qu'on va de l'avant avec la
protection des générations futures des
incidences des changements climatiques
va nous mener à l'échec ce n'est pas une
bonne cible
mais ça va arriver à une chèque il faut
doubler la sebli sinon vous vous dites
avoir fait beaucoup pour lutter contre
les ges mais le canada est un des pires
e pays émetteurs et en fonction de sa
population dans toute cette machine
questions par rapport au québec d'abord
on est d'accord avec la demande du
premier ministre
québec monsieur legault à savoir que le
québec devrait avoir préséance sur ces
questions deuxièmement promettez vous
après cette jugement en quarts mais
britannique de ne plus essayer de faire
traverser un pipeline au canada
après dix ans d échec de monsieur harper
ils ne rient russe à faire passer parce
qu'il n'a pas compris que vous devez
travailler avec les personnes
autochtones vous avez travaillé avec les
collectivités locales vous devez
respecter la science environnementale
nous on a mis de l'avant un processus
qui respecte tout cela nous travaillons
avec les provinces pour nous assurer
qu'il n'y a pas de problèmes
environnementaux
voilà ce que veut faire le projet doit
ses 69 notre façon d'aller de l'avant
est une façon responsable
voilà il ne reste plus de temps monsieur
trudeau c'est un vote retour de poser
une question à n'importe quel autre chef
minutes nous avons réduit les impôts
pour les petites entreprises
un taux de 9% nous avons aussi réduit
les impôts des canadiens et des
canadiennes
nous savons que les crédits d'impôts
pour les plus riches n'aide en rien
l'économie
les échecs sur dix ans donc n'ont rien
fait la plateforme de monsieur chiffres
du moins ce qu'on en a vu parce que la
plupart de cette plateforme est et ce
crétin c'est un petit peu comme dr
lessard pas très bien fonctionné pour
l'ontario mais sa plateforme vise à
réduire l'impôt des mines anti les
multimillionnaires de l'ordre de 50
milles de là c'est plus que la plupart
des greffons par année et posez votre
question
premièrement monsieur trudeau vous
semblez fallu une fixation sur la
politique provinciale
on les libéraux ont besoin d'un chef en
ontario ici ça vous intéresse à ce point
là soyez chef des libéraux en ontario
votre politique fiscale signifie que 80
% des familles de la classe moyenne ne
paye plus d'impôt que quand vous avez
pris pour enfin a servi de sortir trois
s'étaient précipités les libéraux ont
voté contre
vous avez pris une idées conservatrices
alors pourquoi voteriez-vous contre moi
j'ai voté contre vos hausses d'impôts
sur les canadiens nous tenons à protéger
ses prestations parce que c'est fondé
sur les principes presser les époux pour
tous les canadiens nous avons une baisse
d'impôts pour tous on va faire revenir
la crédits dépôts fait un tour chez
arrêté pour le soir pour le débat libre
mais ce truc vous n'avez pas répondu la
question suivante pourquoi utilisez-vous
de l'ordre de 50 mille dollars
les impôts payés par les
multimillionnaires au canada péter
velits répondre à la question de m
une conférence de presse muselée pas
répondu à cette question ce soir vous
avez pas répondu à une question depuis
que vous êtes premier ministre je suis
assis en face de vous n'avez jamais
répondu à une question de questions
durant la période de questions
dans la chambre des communes et rubrouck
permettez monsieur terminée moi je vais
éliminer vos aux dépôts sur les petits
entrepreneurs vous avez dit que c'était
des fruits noirs si vous aller couper
les services pour les audois est ce que
vous n'avez personne ne vous entend vous
avez augmenté alors intervenir deux
experts toutefois j'ai une proposition
vous faire qu'en est il de cette idée
qui a été posée à l'unanimité à
l'assemblée nationale du québec à savoir
une déclaration unique d'impôt cela
permettrait d'économiser 5 millions de
dollars pour nos deux états n'est ce pas
une bonne façon d'économiser de l'argent
de simplifier les choses pour les gens
les entreprises et même pour les
gouvernements vous parlez de la coupe et
si on aurait une vue unique pour les
québécois ben je suis le seul chef
fédéral qui peut tenir cet engagement
non pas dans une position où j'aurai et
vous aurez besoin de mon lit je tiens à
simplifier la vie des québécois pour
qu'ils venaient à remplir qu'une seule
déclaration de revenus je vous parlais
beaucoup de réductions d'impôts mais
voici la réalité des canadiens peuvent
canadiennes et canadiens pour regarder à
travers le pays et voir l'incidence des
réductions des conservateurs des
réductions des services des réductions
dans les soins santé les réductions de
services pour les plus vulnérables de la
société monsieur trudeau vous semblez
beaucoup mieux la façon dont vous parlez
vous avez fait exactement la même chose
vous avez donné de l'argent plus riche
monsieur trudeau mais ce truc dont
messieurs vous pourrez répondre ensuite
monsieur bernier en vertu de la
politique de trudeau les canadiens ils
travaillent de plus en plus dur ils ont
du mal à joindre les deux bouts
selon notre politique nous allons mettre
plus d'argent dans leurs poches et nous
allons protéger des services comme les
services de santé l'éducation ou est ce
qu'on va trouver l'argent
on va réduire l'aide pour les grandes
sociétés et on va réduire l'aide
internationale de 25% en plus en une
réduction d'impôts pour tous
canadien mais son père puisse améliorer
leur quotidien des 10 fiscaux ciblés ils
ne veulent pas réduire les impôts pour
tous les canadiens
nous on aurait deux taux d'imposition se
serait équitable pour tout le monde tout
le monde économiserait de l'argent et le
coup ce serait 35 milliards de dollars
économisés
mais on le fera seulement une fois que
le budget a été équilibrée les surplus
nous serviront elles peuvent être le
signe qu'on va avec tout le respect qui
vous a dû me susi vous allez alors bon
que ce soit une minorité ou majorité
si vous votez pour le député vert c'est
comme ça que vous voilà le gouvernement
peut vous voulez monsieur bernier a dit
mme faust et avec monsieur trudeau les
déficits seront sans fin les canadiens
vont devoir débourser de plus en plus
pour servir de la bière bio nous allons
équilibrer but justement de vous
prétendez être conservateur pourtant
vous ne voulez pas équilibrer le budget
en deux ans montant de 70 milliards de
dollars de dettes et vous allez tout en
sachant que les familles canadiennes
paient plus que 400 $ pour le service de
la dette chaque année alors elle vous
les vrais conservateurs hindous non je
crois que vous êtes libéral pourquoi est
ce que vous prétendez être quelque chose
que vous n'êtes pas justement à ce sujet
là je ne suis pas sûr de savoir quel
maxime dernier j'ai devant moi
est ce que c'est le maxsym d'année des
années 90 qui était séparatistes ou
est-ce que le maxime bernier qui était
responsable des délégués en société est
ce que c'est le maxime bernier qui a
défendu la gestion de l'offre
il ya un contraste réclame à cette
élection
le seul truc dos au rugby déficits sans
fin des augmentations d'impôts pour
défrayer ses déficits
nous nous allons baisser les impôts pour
tous les canadiens nous allons faire
revenir des crédits d'impôt très prisés
comme le crédit d'impôt pour les arts et
le sport nous allons augmenter nos
quotidiens au régime des pagnes études
et nous allons mettre en place un crédit
d'impôt sur les rénovation
écoresponsable
nous allons également réduire notre aide
internationale pour que l'argent reste
au canada
alors passons aux débats ouverts
commencés merci beaucoup je suis maxime
bernier et je défends les canadiens je
suis maxime bernier et je suis quelqu'un
qui ne se soucient pas d'avoir des
débats de départ très gai sujet qui
n'intéresse pas les canadiens et
déclarations sur une ville est pas déjà
être de façon à aider tous les canadiens
vous ne voulez pas abolir le cartel de
la gestion de l'offre
vous ne voulez pas réduire l'aide là
m'est étrangère l'aide internationale
pour pouvoir équilibrer le budget c'est
pas du tout ça j'ai dit qu'on allait
réduire les néo international du canada
de 25% pour rennes où il compenser pour
les réductions d'impôts grave équilibrer
le budget c'est quoi
on va on va se battre on va vous
défendre monsieur trudeau il dit de
belles paroles mais il donne déjà
d'années dé l'argent aux sociétés aux
sociétés les plus riches qui gardent les
paradis fiscaux ouvert et garde les les
échappatoires bien vivante
on n'est pas là pour les riches on est
là pour monsieur madame tout le monde
on va livrer formule d'un régime
d'assurance médicaments on va lutter
contre les changements climatiques
on va fournir des soins dentaires mais
voilà pourquoi
les fontes nous avons investi dedans les
canadiens nous avons fait un choix fort
différent et un choix fonction de celui
que propose un brushing
nous avons sorti plus de 900 mille
canadiens de la pauvreté nous avons
sorti des personnes âgées de la pauvreté
nous mettons plus d'argent dans les
poches des étudiants et plus d'un
million d'emplois la plupart à temps
plein ont été créés au cours des quatre
dernières années mais il reste encore
fort à faire et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous devons continuer sur la
même voie parce que la lutte pour les
changements climatiques et pour notre
économie c'est important il faut réagir
à cette crise climatique et il faut
comprendre que c'est quelque chose qui
va aider l'économie
il ya énormément de débouchés
économiques si on cesse d'utiliser les
complices et de le passer le plus
rapidement possible vous vous continuer
d'utiliser cela vous parce que votre
cible c'est seulement vous allez c'est
seulement la moitié de ce qu'il faut
faire dans ces élections on parle de
confiance on parle d'élection nous
sommes au beau milieu d'une crise
climatique nous avons besoin des adultes
assis autour de tables précise le quai
façon responsable
c'est un bon point surélevé pour qui
voulons lutter je veux lutter pour les
québécois et uniquement pour les
québécois si on est d'accord avec le
gouvernement du canada très bien si
c'est le contraire nous allons lutter
c'est ce qu'a toujours fait bloc
québécois
la vérité c'est que sous justin trudeau
la vie va coûter de plus en plus cher il
va continuer à augmenter les impôts
cette taxe carbone va augmenter il a
peur de vous dire quels seront ces
hausses de taxes avec les conservateurs
qu'on va équilibrer le budget protéger
nos services notre tarification de la
pollution est d'avantagé canadiens que
son plan conclu ce segment et ce débat
nous vous remercions tous bien entendu
nous remercions les personnes qui ont
posé des questions assez que tous les
téléspectateurs et notre auditoire en
personne comme rappelle le débat en
français aura lieu cette semaine jeudi à
20h heure de l'est merci au nom des
autres animateurs et au nom de
ce pont soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
m